Go to amazon.com forward slash Joe and
you will get one free audio book and you
can also try the service
for free for 30 days.
Amazon is an amazing service with
hundreds of thousands of titles.
It is something you will absolutely
become addicted to if you are the type of
person that gets stuck in traffic a lot.
I've completely abandoned radio.
I don't listen to anything anymore.
I got a new car and my new card is
supposed to have XM radio but it didn't,
you know,
and
so I'm supposed to like
drop it off at the,
uh,
the dealership,
first world problems,
anybody.
But,
um,
in the meantime I just started using my
iPhone in the car cause you know that
all Bluetooth's up now nowadays
and it works flawlessly.
And I started listening to podcasts.
Oh really?
Yeah.
And most of it has been
this hardcore history.
And uh,
Dan,
I just started doing audio books as well.
I'm listening to a Carl
Sagan is demon haunted world.
And it's like,
why?
You know,
why just sit in your fucking
car listening to nonsense,
listening to dumb Djs and radios and you
could choose exactly what you listened
to.
I never even thought about it because I
always just relied on the XM cause opie
and Anthony are awesome and they're on it,
you know,
and I listened to them and I listened to
Howard and I would occasionally listen
to,
uh,
there was like an MMA show that they did.
And you know,
there's,
um,
the,
uh,
sports guy for row,
I think it's pretty funny.
But other than that,
that was it.
I wouldn't,
you know,
like,
what am I doing?
I'm just just idly like
letting things come at me.
Like Channel Surfing instead
of choosing your watch.
Yeah.
And the beautiful thing about
audible is it's very like,
it's like a really extensive
collection of different kinds of books.
They have the war of art,
that Pressfield Book that
I talk about all the time,
they have the Stephen King books.
They have.
I mean,
it's just,
uh,
an awesome collection of
audio books and old shows.
They have a lot of standup comedy on it.
And a,
if you go to audible.com
forward slash Joe,
you will save yourself some money.
So go there,
check out audible.
It's fucking bad ass.
All right,
so good.
It's all good.
We're also bought two.
I know there's a long ass every,
a sponsor ads.
Okay,
so I'll to that next step also brought
to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n,
I,
t.
A.
And a if you've never
been to on it before.
There's a lot of,
a lot of weirdness about that website.
You go there and you know,
what the fuck are you doing here?
What's,
what are you sound that's different today?
It looks like you guys,
you have a fitness equipment
that looks a lot like weapons.
You have maces and clubs and
something that looks like armor.
That's not what's going on folks.
That's not the dolce diet part from like
dolce with his ultimate grocery guide.
Um,
it's a company that's essentially
sells things for human performance.
And A,
I've said this so many times that it
sounds gross coming out of my mouth,
but I'm pretending that there's a
person out here has never heard it.
And that's where,
that's where I'm stuck.
That's my,
um,
that's my motivation.
And the Seattle primary
cares is the new a total.
Yes.
The new vitamin packs that is,
uh,
essentially with,
with a healthy diet.
It's a beautiful supplement.
We decided to go with a combination of,
we put a little bit of Alpha brain in it.
Um,
there's Spirulina,
which is God so fucking healthy for you,
a really healthy vitamin C.
The other listing of all
the ingredients is on,
um,
on,
on at.com as long as well as new mood.
So be aware of that.
If you,
uh,
if you take a Ssr i's,
I think they have the new mood.
It,
let me make sure,
because I don't think you're supposed
to really like a vitamin pack per se.
Like it's,
it's vitamins as well.
It's vitamins as well as,
uh,
other nutrients.
And the idea being that like
I take before every show,
I take four Alpha brains for
every show before the UFC.
I take four before I work out.
Like I,
I'm a,
I'm a big believer in supplementation.
I think it's like super important.
Um,
what this is is just like a
little bit of all the Groovy Shit.
There's like strong bone,
which is a bone supplement.
The shroom tech immune,
which is a,
a fascinating supplement
based on the quarter steps,
mushroom,
shroom,
tech sport and shroom Tech
Immune shroom tech sport is uh,
based on uh,
this quarter steps mushroom that um,
they,
they used in high herding a high
altitude hurting populations.
Notice that their cows would eat
these mushrooms and be more active.
So,
uh,
they started experimenting with
them and they found out that it,
I took four of them today
before I worked out.
Man,
it's amazing the difference between
when I take it and when I don't take it.
If I tell you one supplement
that on itself that is app,
you will absolutely feel it.
It's shroom tech sport.
That shit is incredible.
You know,
it's just,
it's,
if you're a like a
hardcore workout person,
you should check it out and check out
the science behind cordyceps mushrooms
because there's a bunch
of weird quarter steps.
Mushrooms,
like the type that
turned ants into zombies.
That's like a type of
quarter steps mushroom too,
but you don't want that kind,
but this a shroom tech
immune actually you're,
it tricks your body into thinking it's
got a cold and your body develops its
immune system to fight off
a cold that doesn't exist.
It's a really interesting
trickery that goes on.
Yeah,
it wasn't priced for,
is that per day?
Per Month?
What?
The bottles there?
Their bottles total primary pack,
is that what you're saying?
Which one of the 2,485
for those from tech thing.
Oh,
that's a bottle of them.
Okay.
Yeah.
You take one of us.
I take,
you could take,
let me see how many is in each bottle.
30 capsules and he just got down.
Just go down.
Well,
if you look,
look at it this way.
If you drink like a cup
of coffee at Starbucks,
it's two bucks.
Right.
If you want to get some
energy before you work out,
you grab a cup of coffee that's two bucks.
It's way more than two bucks,
right?
It's a little bit more how much?
Four bucks.
But I get to train to,
um,
I,
I guarantee you that,
uh,
you're,
you know,
like the amount of effect that you're
going to get is a worthwhile effect to the
point where you would
look at it the same way.
Looking at a cup of coffee before workout,
which I like to do too.
It's,
it has a real impact man.
This,
it's,
it's pretty sweet.
It's nice to have like there's
a lot of supplements like,
man,
am I feeling this?
But when I take shroom tech,
I'm like,
God damn,
this is a amazing,
it's amazing how much more pep you have.
You know?
I would like to see it measured.
We need to do it with athletics.
It's hard though.
It's like you,
you,
you do things with athletes.
You got to know like if it's the same guy,
you got to know like what
was his workout this week?
Did he lift weights this week
and not do it the other week?
Yeah.
How do you know like did he fuck
all night that he'd go to sleep?
It's like,
it's hard to like completely quantify
whether or not fitness supplements because
the edge they give you is fairly subtle.
You know,
like the edge and Alpha brain.
Fairly subtle.
It,
it actually used to be a
little stronger in Alpha brain.
It used to be,
have a little bit more of an effect
where I used to only take three or two,
like a tolerance.
We're not,
but too many people had
an intolerance for it.
Don't highlight that woman's for judge.
Yeah,
don't do that dude.
That's Rudy.
Well maybe it's photo-shopped.
She was well,
she's agent.
Well there's a lot of um,
that have uh,
those booty genetics being a rude racist.
Oh,
because it's stereotypical
because of the earthquake.
The earthquake gave him
big booties on their butts.
Is that the pay all don't
live in Japan and fuck head.
There's a thing called China is
a million billion Asians there.
I know all about them.
Orient your,
your sound rude as fuck on it.com.
O.
N n.
I.
T.
So yeah,
the stuff that you haven't seen,
if you've been there before,
it's probably the total primary care.
Uh,
the t plus testosterone supplement
and all the walnut almond bark shit,
the cashew butter shit.
So go check it out.
Use a code name,
Rogan,
and you could save 10% off
any of the supplements.
All right,
sweet bitches and oh yeah.
If you try supplements
and you don't like it,
you,
there's a 90 day 100%
money back guarantee.
And what that means is you don't
even have to return the product.
Just say this stuff shocks chucks,
you know,
to say shocks and then
you get your money back,
your fox,
because no one's trying to rip you off.
Just trying to sell you cool shit.
All right.
The show begins.
Oh,
can I say real quick that
the Sacramento punchline,
Oh yeah.
Segment a punchline.
This weekend,
Friday and Saturday with Sam Tripoli and
Tony Hinchcliffe and Cobbs Sunday and
tickets are all on sale@deathsquad.tv.
Sweet dirty bitches.
Boom.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Ari Shaffir.
We're losing Ari.
He's leaving the great west coast to go
back to New York for the big flooding
party.
Tundra scheduled this summer.
The flooding party of New York.
It's in the way.
It's an October,
right?
Oh,
it's going to end it to happen.
That mother fucker is going underwater,
dude.
Yeah.
Try is going to be a wash.
All of that beautiful and
billion dollar apartments.
Oh God.
Fucked there.
Fuck.
That's going under water,
man.
How far up is it going to go into water?
It's going to be far.
Do you guys talking about the years?
There is without a doubt.
There's some raising of
the ocean levels and uh,
they're,
they're going to have an issue with Lara,
the increased frequency
of tropical storms and a,
their impact on the east coast.
And it's very likely that there's
portions of the east coast,
especially like the low areas
of New York and port cities,
they're going to get
hit hard by this stuff.
The Shit we saw in New Jersey.
They call that a hundred year storm,
but according to Shane Smith from vice.com
who I quote all the time cause he's
my man crush.
Um,
he says that those hundred year storms
are going to be placed again taking place
two and three times a year,
two or three times a year straight from
nothing from once every hundred years to
two or three times a year.
He said that's the future.
He said if the climate,
climate change happens at the base,
it's very difficult.
When will that happen to time?
I don't know.
They could,
it could happen soon,
but do you mean like a thousand years?
No,
no,
no.
Like within our lifetime,
the issue is that we've fucked up
the atmosphere so much that there's,
there's a negative effect
that's happening on,
um,
on the planet because of it.
Now it's very controversial and that's
the Republicans don't want to even,
it's like,
it becomes like a conservative
versus a liberal talking point.
Hi.
Why don't the Republicans care?
Because they think it's
going to inhibit business.
Okay.
It's really interesting.
It's a fascinating study because one hand,
they have a point that the climate on
the earth has changed radically over the
course of its existence.
And that,
you know,
during the dinosaur era,
the,
the climate was very
different than it is today.
And we also know there was an ice age
just 10,000 plus years ago or half of
North America was covered in ice.
So the climate has varied.
Um,
so we,
we know that regardless of
how humans have affected it,
the climate changes all the time.
So there's a lot of people that don't
want to look at some of the mitigating
factors.
And one of them is this,
the heating up due to carbon dioxide and
due to fluorocarbons and all the shit
that people use.
But you know what another
one is what cow farts.
Oh yeah,
it's really bad.
But we have a lot more cows now,
right?
We make all the cows probably congestion.
Well,
if you think back though,
to like maybe 10,000 years ago,
who knows how many counselor were
and there was also a mammoth.
Can you imagine what mammoths far too?
Like birds.
Think about,
how about buffalo?
Think about that shit.
Herds of Buffalo.
Think about how many
buffalo would be that farts.
Millions of buffaloes just
crack and farts all day.
That never talked about
that with the Indians.
The old times.
Well,
you know,
that's a real,
it's a real issue in India like this,
this,
the population like suffers
because of like anywhere you are.
If you're living around that
you're breathing in shit gas.
Yeah.
And that's what you breathing
in and it's a contributor to,
you know,
to,
to bad shit in the atmosphere.
It's methane,
it's methane and it's,
it's uh,
there's also,
there's other kinds of
toxins that are carried in a,
in that gas to what happened to India.
There's silly,
it used to be the place known for like
free thinking and Zen and now it's the
fucking gang rape plus.
Yeah,
right.
They went bad.
Something went wrong.
So the opposite.
I think it's an overpopulation issue.
I think when humans
get to a certain level,
life almost gets devalued and
they just lose their humanity.
I think that's why in China,
like with the overpopulation thing,
we've all heard horrific stories about
people drowning female babies and shit
because they can only have one baby.
You know there's madness.
That's,
that's absolute madness,
you know?
I mean that is,
that's humanities.
If once you've drowned your fucking baby,
like where are you going?
Like well what is this life about?
You've dragged your own
baby cause it was a girl.
What is this life for you?
And I understand that we need
girls to you fucking crazy asshole.
But it's everybody looks at her
and it'd be the ones having them,
but they're also,
there's so few they need like
there's so few resources there.
I mean it's terms of like there's so
much poverty that when a son is born that
song can go to work for you and that Sun
can like he can take over the business.
They can,
you know,
whereas they,
they feel like a woman can't do that.
Then a woman that was happening as much
now that like times have changed over
the last 25 years.
I'm sure it has there to change,
but I don't think it's changed
as much as it has here.
And when the pig dramas,
babies per capita,
no babies,
cause they're like,
Nah,
you know I can do accounting work.
Oh Man.
There was a horrible show on HBO about
people that were selling their kids
because China is so poor.
People would sell the kid,
they would sell them up to
like five and six years old.
And this guy,
this guy was yelling because his brother,
he was five and I think his brother
was younger than five and his dad was
selling his brother and he's just said
how he never forgave his dad because his
dad sold his brother,
his younger brother,
man,
I sold,
his brother,
sold them and he was like to,
you know,
sold them off to some fucking white
people or something and wanted her baby.
Oh that's not even a doctor
that's giving them money.
That's what's going on.
You know what?
People were buying babies.
It's better than stealing a baby.
Well I guess the whole
thing is just chaos.
It's just,
I think it's the same
issue as the India issue,
obviously different cultures,
but I think that kind of
overpopulation is really fucking bad.
And My,
my evidence is I feel better
when I'm in small towns.
Like when I go to boulder.
Yeah.
Or,
um,
like I was in,
what's that place up in Utah
where everybody goes skiing,
fail.
Nothing yet.
No,
that's in Colorado.
Whatever it was.
Do Your valley or some shit.
Okay.
We went to Utah is really small to as
like so calm everybody's tribe and nice
and slow.
Yeah.
Nothing's getting done.
There's no art.
There's no chaos.
There's no craziness.
Has No bad ass music club
that you can go here.
Bad ass new bands coming up.
There's no comedy clubs up there.
But there's also like the less
of the negative impact of humans,
the constant influx of information
that we're getting from each other.
And I think it makes you go crazy when
it's too much to humanize everybody.
That's how it is in New York too.
It's like you don't look at
anybody who's like a person,
you know?
Then we'd nods her head and say,
hello.
Yeah,
New York is so odd,
man.
It's so odd.
It's,
it's a,
it's an experiment in con condensation.
It's an experiment and and
jamming people into tight places.
Yeah.
So many per per block.
Those apartments are ridiculous.
I looked at some people's apartments.
I'm like,
how the fuck is that?
How can you make people pay for that?
Then I went,
I went,
uh,
I saw a place that shower was
just opened into the kitchen,
like the shower door,
which just in the room and then
the bathroom was somewhere else.
Oh my toilet with somewhere else.
But the shower just opened
right there and I'm like,
what do
I,
well it is in its price range.
I'm like,
no,
I'll get a row.
So stupid.
No,
I finally found something.
It's,
I'm,
I looked at some of them that my
friends had when I lived there.
I didn't live in New York.
I lived in new Rochelle.
I mean I lived in New York.
I just didn't live in the city cause
I had a car when I first came and I
couldn't afford to park it
there and I also couldn't,
um,
I needed to be able to drive to gigs a
lot and it was hard to get out of the
city.
It's not that easy.
So I was like,
you know,
and I,
I shouldn't,
I can't,
I can't live here.
But when you would tell people about it,
it was like a thing of shame.
It was weird that I would tell him I
lived in new Rochelle and then like
you don't live in the city if
you don't live in the city,
like they would look down on you.
I absolutely remember,
I remember it so much
that telling you today,
like when I said that I
didn't live in the city,
I live in new Rochelle.
It's almost like a feeling of shame.
Felt it you felt the thing of like,
yeah,
definitely.
I felt the,
um,
uh,
almost like an ad or inadequacy.
I have never observed a geographical
bias as much as New York to New Yorkers.
It's so weird.
There's nothing like it.
It's nothing like it.
They lose 12 players.
They would rate higher if
they came from New York.
Then from somewhere else,
House Jab,
Judah food as
Brooklyn tattooed on his back,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
it's uh,
the,
the I iPhone.
I'm,
I'm from New York.
Toughness claims.
If you know you were in nom in this shit,
that's all it takes.
Flying overhead day.
Just relax.
There's a,
there's an issue also with,
uh,
people that can't it up
because of the weather.
You're going to get that.
You're going to get people cutting up,
you know,
the overpopulation plus
insanely shit weather.
Sometimes it gets,
it gets bad.
There's a lot of attitude there.
I wonder how long it's going to take
for you to get enough fight your first
couple,
couple of days.
You've got to have that start
again.
Yeah.
The only pick on guys.
That's,
sorry.
That's the best way to get into
fights around says try not to get hit.
Yeah.
Want to fuck around with big people.
Some people think that getting
hits like a badge of courage,
you know,
take one and then I feel my own
blood and that's what I get.
Crazy.
Hmm.
It seems like you're approaching this,
this whole endeavor in the wrong way.
Let's just talk hunter.
When they're not looking at you,
there's a whole a data
sheet in front of you.
Let's go over the numbers here.
Spleen.
Well,
you get benefit versus cost ratio.
See how my nose has no blood.
So I got to talk about
something because a,
on the podcast yesterday we
talked about this website where a,
this guy,
Lloyd Irvin has this a marketing
website and we were making fun of it.
And so he called me up today and uh,
he was upset that we made fun of it.
But I told him,
I said,
listen,
we can't make fun of something that's
not stupid and if something looks
ridiculous,
it's,
I mean like you insult people's
intelligence and that there,
it becomes humor,
you know?
And his attitude is very interesting
because he's a very successful marketer.
And one thing I gotta to say,
it's like it's,
I don't know,
like the,
the guys had some,
some issues.
I know,
but I don't know both sides of the story.
I just know all the bullshit and the
rumors that you hear on the Internet.
But as far as like what
he's been able to do,
he's a phenomenal marketer.
Like this guy figured out how to get
like way bigger schools than anybody else
has ever to do and then teaches people
how to do it and it's super effective.
He's the Whitney of Jujitsu,
the Whitney Cummings,
she,
you love her dude.
You like bring her up all the time.
She's your example of like a hard worker.
Yeah.
Well the dude's definitely a hard worker,
but I think in that,
that that style of marketing,
it leaves you so open to be criticized.
And I'm aware of that personally myself
because of my involvement with on it
because there's been times where the
people at Onnit have made like an ad or
something or said something and add that.
I thought it was ridiculous.
So I made fun of it on the show.
I would come on the podcast and we
play the guide with the muscles.
That was like with the girl.
Remember that ad that we played?
When was it 20 tech make
talking about Kissing Mickey.
I talk.
Yeah,
the guy kissing his biceps,
but we don't have the other part
where there was like a girl.
They might have removed that immediately.
Why can't we get,
I'll get it.
I'll tell RBC said,
well I don't know if that weight lifted
dude wants it out cause I remember his
girl was pissed that I talked about
and laughed at that and we met the guy.
Everybody knows now I'll
have Aubrey said it over.
I'll have Aubrey centered over,
but my point is I make,
I make fun of myself.
I think the only reason why someone would
not want to be made fun of is first of
all,
you think it would affect your business,
which is valid,
but also because you don't want to look
at the fact that what you're doing most
of it.
Yeah.
Well you make it fun of me.
It's like you should sign.
This is what I told them.
This is the other thing I told him,
boy,
cause I like Lloyd.
You know my interactions with
him have always been cool.
Even though I think the
marketing shits and salting,
I said,
you need to do this.
If you're going to do these things and
then give them to somebody to look at
somebody who's like a critical person,
it was going to go,
no,
no.
Send them to me.
I'll tell him,
I'll tell you what the
fuck's wrong with it.
You,
you can't make people think
you think they're stupid.
You can't because then you're funny
because then you become funny.
You become a silly person when
you know you write drafts to your,
to to yourself.
He wrote an email to himself.
He got busted like writing an
email and a her tending it.
It was this expert that was
emailing him and his interest.
The way he looked at
it was very different.
Mr. Keith,
he was,
this is how he looked at
it was very fascinating.
He was like,
if you saw an ad on TV and a
celebrities endorsing something,
do you think they really say those words?
Like the reading something
that someone wrote?
Oh yeah,
so I,
I thought it was interesting,
like that's how he looked at it.
So he looked at it like he's
creating a bit of fiction,
but ultimately his product is legitimate.
That's how he looked at it,
which is I kind of,
I see that kind of a leap.
Yeah,
well not really.
Not really.
If,
if the product wasn't legitimate,
I would say yes.
But since the pro,
I know for a fact that that guy has made
a lot of people a lot of money with his
techniques,
I guess marketing techniques.
He's made them a lot of
fucking money so it does work.
So it's interesting that he's
saying what he's saying is it like,
what are you doing for putting on a show?
Disney had that with,
with people come out of a
movie and everyone like,
oh,
it was great.
It was amazing.
And they kept out later.
They're all Disney
employees and it's like,
oh,
all the people that were saying that
you're making people believe that this
person is not the person misleading.
Treat them like they're fools.
And then it becomes funny.
We had a guy on our message board,
Brian,
I don't know if you remember this,
who was a musician and he started uh,
making threads about his
music under other names.
It didn't know that we
could find that out.
He didn't understand why the people
that are like not Internet savvy,
they don't understand that.
That actually happens a lot.
A lot.
I love when people got called
out on that when they're like,
okay,
flap,
oh spam or whatever it is.
You just know the type of writing
and everyone just calls you on it.
Well we would get that a lot when
we were we people and we still do,
when you ban people,
you really only band there,
their persona,
they can always come back always
like go through proxies or whatever.
And then those are like
the Internet savvy guys.
They know how to do it.
But like a guy like this musician
guy was just being a douchebag.
Like you're pretending you're music
is awesome and you tell anybody,
oh my God,
that Shit I've ever seen.
Like,
and maybe he's a good guy,
but sometimes people make shit decisions
and you might make a shit decision
because she grew up with
a bunch of fucking idiots.
All right?
It's not,
I'm not blaming you if you decided to
write a fucking thread and you know,
make some shit about your music
being awesome when it's really you.
I'm not blaming you.
I really am not.
But what I'm saying is you are,
you're a look at it.
Look,
look at your life as a mathematical
equation from birth to the point where you
find yourself making threads
about your own music.
Okay?
Clearly you're in debt.
You're,
you're in some sort.
You've not eve not balanced.
Your sheets are not balanced.
You're in some sort of a debt type
situation where you're functioning and
properly.
Right?
And what is that?
Is it because you didn't get enough love?
Is it because you didn't
get enough education?
Did you get enough love or education?
You were abused.
You grew up around illiterates.
You grew up around.
I grew up around religious folk.
It's something went wrong.
A lot of comics do that too though,
but they're weak bitches.
I think it's because I think it's
whatever you think your talent level is,
is not met by the,
um,
by the respects it's getting
and it just drives you crazy.
I ain't got to do something.
That's a really common thing with comics.
It was a cop.
I remember having it myself.
Completely unwarranted.
When I first started doing comedy.
Hi,
this is Bob Smith from it.
My frequency,
I'm calling about artists or fear fears,
a great young talent on this guy.
I saw him absolutely kill.
When you start off doing comedy,
you never realize that you're on
essentially like fourth grade,
10,
a 10 year path to competence.
You know?
And when,
when I started out,
I had done all these other things,
like athletic things and I had
gotten pretty good pretty quick.
It's stuff like martial arts.
So I was like,
I'm just going to get awesome
at this and just watch comedy.
Yeah,
no,
you need to.
And then somewhere along the
line you also realize you're,
you're,
you're learning yourself too.
You're not just learning jokes.
You're learning yourself through life.
Like standup is a,
is a,
an occupation and it's an art form,
but it's also a path of life.
Like there's,
it's like there's,
in creating anything you're
also finding out about yourself.
That's my theory on
why beginning standups,
we'll always do jokes about
how they can not get laid.
How they can't beat anywhere up there was
give over to the Kroger but you could,
you could take me sir
or Ma'am or whatevers.
But then they stopped saying that
because they hit whatever age.
You're like,
oh no,
I can beat a few people up here
and I get laid once in a while.
I'm not going to this little kid anymore.
You get more confidence.
Your style of comedy too.
It's like you would never say that someone
could beat you up if you thought that
you could beat them up.
Cause that would sort of invalidate
everything else you're saying your,
your whole style of comedy is like,
well you might not want to hear this,
but here's the truth.
You know,
and as soon as you start pretending one
way or the other to sort of placate or
sometimes,
well it's new comics,
all we do that,
then it goes away.
Kind of feel like you have to do that
because you want to make them like you.
It's like so bad,
so bad.
That's the only,
that's the hardest part.
In the beginning it's like just
actually figuring out how to do it,
how to just get in front of people and
not look like a Douche bag and you don't
realize what you,
how do you come off either.
It's hard to figure that out.
So while it's not,
yeah.
And again,
I don't blame the people.
I don't want to talk to them
if they're bad at comedy.
It's very rare that I
want to talk to anybody,
but I don't blame him.
I don't,
you know,
it's like,
it ain't easy.
It's,
it's doesn't make a lot of
sense what you're doing.
You're,
you're up there talking and
it makes people like laugh.
Like how the fuck does that work?
It's a long process.
So a lot of the secret like
what is going to be code unlock.
Yeah.
Well that's why classes or gross,
that's why people teaching those
classes are gross because you can't,
first of all the people that
teach almost invariably suck.
Yeah.
Okay.
Amy Schumer's pulling up.
That's the best.
Uh,
I told Peter Jennings
class once I audited it.
Yeah.
Oh Jesus Christ.
And he goes,
I'll let you audit for free once.
Mike,
I'll definitely be there.
Oh,
sweet cheese.
We pots a jokes first.
You have set up,
Dan,
do you have set up then punchline,
oh,
there's a dude.
What interested are you sure
there's not set up set up punchline,
why would you have to seven?
He's the only guy that I've ever actively
like cock blocked from going on a
stage.
Yeah.
I told that story was Chris Mcguire
was fucking auditioning for Mitzi.
Hey fucker.
Amy Schumer,
Michelle Ladies and gentlemen.
Chris Mcguire was a
auditioning for Mitzi and uh,
he was going up at an open mic night
and for some reason she thought it'd be
funny to let Peter Chan
host the open mic night.
Like,
I don't know what the
fuck that was all about.
She's so crazy.
She was so awesome,
you know?
Yeah.
I know.
I don't go to a store anymore,
but she was awesome.
Which would Mitzi short did like
her just keeping that place alive.
Her creating that fucking place.
The funny farm.
It's amazing if you have all of these men,
you've got to have one of these coco cafe.
You don't drink coffee though,
Huh?
Is that caffeine?
Caffeine.
You drink soda?
Nothing.
Look at you.
You fucking sexy bitch.
It tastes healthy.
It tastes like chocolate milk,
but it's got a little
bit of caffeine in it.
It's so delicious.
They stay sent us a fucking
shitload of that stuff.
Yeah.
You wouldn't let them host
from McGuire showcase thing.
Yeah,
I wouldn't.
I came in,
um,
and I called up the comic stores had
fucked that I'm hosting open Mike easily
after news radio.
Could have been in Fairfax,
Fairfax,
sure factor.
So you hosted the open mic part,
but the fucking with
five people in the room.
Oh yeah.
I started the show off at four in
the afternoon or whatever it was.
Yes,
I was there.
I was there all night.
It's the dregs until nine and then after
them I did like 20 minutes about Peter
Chin about I couldn't let them.
Hey you fuck hi ladies and gentleman.
This is the part of the show where
Amy Schumer comes in and I get a hug.
Hi Amy.
We're full of Amy Schumer.
Yeah,
have a seat.
What's up?
What happened?
Shit,
I don't hear
any volume anymore on who or what
are you pulling it out?
Your
maybe you went deaf.
Ooh,
I like,
that's weird.
The died.
Did you hit the buy button?
You guys hear it though?
Did you hit the mute button?
Oh,
that piece of shit.
They send us these things,
isn't there?
Very nice.
Skullcandy thank you for
sending us these things.
However this fucking button sucks.
A fat cock
stupid button are cute though.
Thanks.
I'll sponsor like a poker player now.
Oh,
you think so?
Let me go slow and make
us look more professional.
Totally.
Okay,
good.
Super Rare.
Look at this.
You haven't been to this spot.
I was going to go.
When you saw the Werewolf,
did you panic?
Oh,
I freaked out when I saw it.
I forgot it was.
There was a
little warning would be cool.
This is the greatest
thing that's ever existed.
Really.
There's been so much
fucking Werewolf.
I'm telling you.
What a disappointment.
Come on baby.
You say,
how long did you get
your freak on last night?
What happened?
I should have been drunk.
Oh Shit.
I was like to do a lot
of stuff and I was like,
oh,
it'll be funny.
It'll be funny to be hungover
tomorrow having to do all this.
You think it's funny to
be hung over it like shit.
I just don't care about anything.
That's totally like a junkie.
[inaudible] yeah,
you're right.
I definitely
skipping denial.
Did you ever think that as a comic that
you can't be completely enlightened or
you will stop being funny?
Wait that I would never be completely
like,
you have to be a fuck up almost.
She can't really completely have your
shit together or you will see cease to be
as impulsive,
hence cease to be as funny.
I've no,
I liked the idea that I would
ever strive to be enlightened.
Like I just try to not kill myself,
but I just try to keep
out of a depression.
Maybe that was a grandiose
way of explaining it,
getting out of bed in the morning.
But do you,
I mean,
you seek,
you seek personal improvement,
right?
You seek Saturday,
you see clarity,
so in,
in,
and that's,
it's doing that.
It's like,
it's always the pursuit of enlightenment,
but you just kind of always accept the
fact that you're never gonna get there.
That's one of the reasons why people who
like claim to be enlightened or really
pursuing it.
Like,
you know,
Yogi style wood beads and
robes are so annoying.
Cause because,
you know,
and I know no one's getting,
it's not happening.
Yeah.
I don't think so.
I don't know anything about poker so much.
But,
uh,
I remember like,
I think it was Jessica,
some Jessica was playing
poker heads up and like,
she obviously had been
reading the secret a ton,
you know,
and she was just like secret in it.
And like it was just getting far.
And then you just saw all
of a sudden she one hand,
it was just like the secret
was gone and she lost it all.
And it was like,
no,
you're not.
You're like everybody else.
There's no trick.
You can't control life.
We're all just going to have
to experience so much pain.
What a weird notion.
The secret.
Yeah,
it's really weird.
It's really weird that they promoted that.
You can just imagine that life would be
different and it would become different
made essentially.
That's the message.
I mean,
obviously there's more to it
than that normal talking about.
I know what you say,
but there's actually a
lot of good thoughts,
thoughts in there?
Well,
there,
there's some interesting ideas in there,
but it's also misinterpret
quantum physics.
Like the way they misinterpret the way,
like the Observer.
See,
I saw that documentary.
The first one,
the um,
the,
the secret.
And then there was another
one like through the,
through the owner.
The other secret.
Yeah.
Something like that.
But they have this doctor
a lot of secrets.
His doctor quantum thing where they
show you that in measuring these quantum
particles,
it actually changes the
behavior of the particle.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Cause someone is,
someone is observing what's happening.
But that's what it is.
It's a lie.
What it is,
is the measuring of it itself changes
the reaction because you're measuring it
with something.
Oh yes.
So these quantum particles or our co,
there's somehow another
measured and in measuring them,
you change their behavior
because you're interfering.
Measure my hangover right now.
Well that makes sense.
Made sense to me.
Exactly.
So all these people that feel like you
can change things by looking at them are
just crazy.
They just want to be able to
control everything like wizards.
Well they love the idea
of things being managed.
Yeah.
You know,
people love the idea of being able to
literally wish your way to a dream.
Life isn't all about control.
I had a photo of a house,
three years living in it.
Have you had to sit there conversations
like that you like from real people
being like,
oh,
this is a picture of my
house I'm going to live in.
And you're like,
you're a Barista.
There was a sweet girl who was so
think friends with Kelly Kirsten.
She was friends with Kelly Kirsten and
she would come right Kelly Kirsten's
comic or could have been
at one point in time,
might have had one of the funniest
sets have ever seen in my life.
Never really.
It doesn't make me an orange peel back.
Hit the height.
I thought she was going to write what
the bleep do we know that's the book.
Yeah,
that's it.
That's secret number two.
Okay.
We're sort of friend comes around and um,
you know,
nice person,
but she's like telling every,
it was a weird thing.
She wasn't bragging,
but she was telling everyone like,
what was,
what was gonna Happen?
You know,
I ain't going to be married.
I'm going to have a child and I'm
going to have a successful business.
And A,
we were like,
okay,
what,
how's that going to happen?
Uh,
do you like you have a boyfriend?
She goes,
no,
I have just seen the secret and I have
decided to live my life through its
principles and it totally works.
It's amazing.
And I go,
really?
She goes,
already,
I feel my life getting better.
I feel I'm definitely moving
in the right direction.
All this is going to happen.
I'm completely clear,
so I'm ready for a healthy relationship.
When you're ready for
a healthy relationship,
that's when it finds you.
And so she's saying all this stuff.
I'm like,
wow.
All right.
That's really cool.
It was a really weird,
she was very nice.
So it wasn't a negative
conversation at all.
So then I don't see her.
Um,
we,
I,
the last I spoke to her
in that conversation,
then I don't see her again until like
maybe a year and a half later she comes to
the UCB and I'm doing a set of the UCB.
So she comes by and I'm like,
hey,
how you doing?
And she goes,
we came to see your sat.
And this now I go,
I go,
oh yeah,
thanks for coming.
I go,
last time I talked to you,
you were like really into the secret,
like what's going on?
And she goes,
I go,
I would love to hear like you progress.
Just like,
I don't know why it's not working.
Oh Man,
I really thought you were
going to say it like Cancun.
Paul out of my life that I want out of
my life and my father got sick and I know
I didn't ask for that because
you can't control the world.
It's like,
yeah,
you're not getting sick has
something to do with you.
But it was fascinating because like
in the text of my life it was like,
you know how like people
that come in now your life,
well not seeing this person like meaner,
having this conversation with her and
then seeing her a year and a half plus
whatever it was later.
And then here's the results.
It was like I get to like
splice the two of them together
and we got to hear it,
but not even have to have a
conversation without worrying.
She like a lot of people
that are really into,
that gets sucked into cults and a lot
of people that get sucked into religions
or yoga or whatever,
people they get,
like some people like need something to
excite them to believe in some new piece
of information.
How this amazing I did all my life.
I've been living without knowledge
that I am in control of my destiny.
I create my universe.
God,
you just want to tell the people
that I've heard you before.
I've heard people exactly like you before.
I'm sorry if I'm not going to get into it.
Yeah,
yeah,
but he can't be even rude if you
you do that.
Right?
It's annoying when people,
they,
when they find something that they're,
they look at you like you're you,
you don't get it,
then you will or,
or they feel bad for you.
Is everybody all that kind
of like smirk like you're,
you're still where you are,
but yeah,
I was doing this,
the meeting.
You should come like that and you're like,
no,
that's cool.
Have Fun.
I was doing this thing for VH one and a,
there's a girl who's working
there seemed so nice.
She seems so like normal
and friendly and uh,
her sister was such a,
like a,
a religious freak that she,
she was actually the first person that
I've ever met in my life who believed in
Satan and she was telling me that
the reason why I can't see Satan,
the saint and scales were
over my eye and yeah.
Okay.
But you really have sessions for people.
Well,
I'm,
I'm fascinated.
He's,
I'm fascinated by people.
If I get a chance to talk to someone
that actually is like that nutty.
Yeah.
But she,
it was funny.
It's like I feel bad for you.
For Real.
I feel bad
for you.
For Real.
You don't believe that?
Wow.
Can't believe you don't believe that.
It was so strange cause I was like totally
like dead facing the whole thing as
if I was like watching like a show I like,
Huh.
Yeah.
It just looks like serving
her because in her mind,
by making me feel bad,
like,
like whenever anybody laughs at you or
they're trying to make you feel bad,
like,
oh,
why are they doing?
They're trying to,
they're socially wrestling,
you're socially wrestling,
they try and take you down.
Right.
And whenever someone does that,
it's like at that only works if
you don't know what it is like.
So as soon as you know what it is,
then it's just silly.
It's just like a social cue.
It's like,
it's like just the most infuriating thing.
And that's also their way of saying,
and I don't think you
know what this means.
Yeah.
God,
it's,
that really pisses me off.
Oh,
it's one of the grossest things ever,
you know?
And,
and,
and people that pretend that
they have secret information,
you know,
you're,
you're pretending what?
You've got some secrets.
Can you think of this one MC on the road,
those working with youth?
No,
he's a feature and he would,
um,
and you would come out and he would like
take his time and bring his coffee on
stage with him before
he would go before me.
But per tenant,
you'd be like,
he'd lay low in the
stool and he'd be like,
so a woo.
Where are you from?
You know,
like he's working the
crowd and I'm just like,
dude,
come on.
And he'd come and he'd be like,
uh,
come to me and be like,
you'll,
you'll enjoy them.
And I'm like,
how to hear?
Uh,
well,
I think it's gross.
It's gotta be gross.
You to have like these douchey guys
that trip on the fact that you're
headlining.
They're all,
they all,
everyone thinks that they
should be headlining.
They're so annoyed that that I am,
and I just explained,
I'm just like,
okay.
Yeah.
I'm like,
God,
you should be headlining.
Like,
I'll just do it for the ride.
Yeah.
Do you want to go back?
Do you want me to bring you back up?
I'll bring you back.
Huh?
Why don't you just bring
your own people on the road?
No,
no,
I do that guy.
I learned my lesson because I
kept getting paired with him.
Like I,
I chose Virginia and be like,
oh,
but you know,
you try to,
you try to bring your own person early
in the game and they're just like,
no,
here's your thousand dollars for eight
shows and we're pairing you with the club
owners nephew.
That's done it twice.
He's going to do 30.
I've never had a road
acts either one of you.
They tried to sabotage you.
Uh,
I think every,
everybody,
everybody goes up before you
is essentially just try it.
It's a complex plot to sabotage.
You
ruined.
They all got together in the guy,
that guy and then people who will
go up the way they bring you up.
If somebody wants to sabotage me,
the most aggressive move is to say,
I hope you guys are ready,
Fara lady
trying to sabotage it or just not.
By the way,
if I ever bring you up now you know
the show just so you can,
if I ever area in a
position to bring you up.
All right,
so
lady
who likes ovaries and
the crowd just prepares,
you know,
the board and to go to the
bathroom and it's just so mean.
And when a lot of times,
you know,
even sometimes the girls will
do it like this next girl,
she is a funny woman.
Just all the words,
the trigger words for people that make it
upset and angry with
you before you even set,
right?
Yeah.
Is it just a sign that
they're not accepting you,
treating you differently?
Yeah.
They're all,
they're trying to be,
you know,
they're trying to passive aggressive.
Yeah.
Well that's how you're taking it.
I think also they feel like some dudes
just don't know what the fuck they're
saying.
Yeah.
Just stammering up there low.
Okay.
Think it's aggressive.
If a girl does it,
it's aggressive because she knows.
She knows.
But then you'll let
people go on after you,
you know,
when you,
you'll like come up the MC and maybe
it's someone you know and you'll make a
joke about them.
You know,
you'll be like,
all right,
a great try if I can,
whatever.
It just has it.
And then you do your whole hour and
then they come back up and they make
reference to what you said an hour ago.
And you're like,
you've been thinking about
saying that for an hour.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Uh,
my best friends are female comics,
so I don't know.
I mean,
oh,
you know what it is,
um,
real competitive,
like in a spa locker room
or the gym locker room,
there's just this,
there's something in the air,
like we're all ready to
fucking kill each other.
It's true.
I don't know why that is.
And then the spa or,
you know,
but you know what,
at the,
where I box in New York,
we're all like,
sort of trying to like get
ready after we worked out and,
but then there was like
this one big black check,
this other like skinny white chick.
And we were,
yeah.
And uh,
and she was just annoying
and she was on her phone.
So anyway,
she leaves and then I'm like,
you know,
trying to bond with the black chick.
Like we all try and do
it.
I'm just like,
I'm like God,
that girl.
Right.
And she's like,
oh,
I didn't mind her.
And I'm like,
Shit.
Yeah.
I'm like,
come on.
And then she goes,
yeah she sorta like came around,
but I was like,
you know,
that girl was the worst so I'll reach out,
in the locker.
But there's just like,
there's just something in the
air where you're just like,
but yeah,
I don't know what it all girls or to
try to improve themselves as well.
It's like a self improvement place
cause it's a gym is a soft fruit jam.
Yeah.
But you know,
girls that go there,
they're like,
they're trying to,
I'm trying to get my anger out.
I'm trying to get some stuff out.
Maybe it's that one.
It's a little tension and
aggressive environment.
It's all women.
A spa,
relax,
relax.
That makes more sense than a boxing gym
because you're going to get naturally
get aggressive women I think at a
boxing gym or a high percentage of them,
like a boxing gym for men.
Like for MS,
more aggressive,
high MMA.
They,
they,
there's
some aggressive people there,
but for the most part,
no.
Most part people chill
out because they train.
Yeah.
When you train a lot you,
you get all your animosity
and anger out that way.
It's like the people that are actually
like some of the nicest people I know are
martial artists.
Totally.
Yeah.
The guys who I know that,
but chickson a spa.
That's weird.
There's just some were even like in an
elevator and you can smell each other's
vaginas,
so it is it just you?
I don't think that's it.
Elevated our re dogs.
What is that?
I want to be the only
pussy smell in the room.
Are you say that,
but the reason why you guys have
coinciding menstrual cycles is pheromonal.
Yeah.
What's that?
What that is going to be like.
You've never talked to her
toes colored pills.
That's ridiculous.
That's not what your nails look like.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Just pheromonal though.
Hormonal.
I
think it's a chemical thing.
Yeah.
The,
the,
the hate that women have for
each other is hormonal chip.
Bummer.
But my best friends,
honestly,
my favorite people to be
around her are female comics.
What about us?
Bitch,
I really take it or
leave it with you guys.
So rude,
but true by you as well.
And the cords wrapped you up.
Something's going on here.
I don't know.
It's hard.
You don't know what you're doing.
My first time in it.
Maybe help Jamie run in
and take care of you.
Just climb of there and
got an assistant finger.
Their son assistant.
Yeah.
It's don't lie to him.
Works for you guys.
He's the guys are saying,
is that a,
is that a derogatory
term to say an assistant?
Um,
I don't know.
You feel slighted?
This is what I think.
I think people shouldn't have labels.
They were going to call him red band.
Do work.
Okay.
Let's never label anyone anymore.
No.
People like,
like working in a place.
What are you doing?
This guy's just a worker guy.
Just doing his shit.
We're all working together.
President.
The guide.
Starting the [inaudible] here
at the Joe Rogan experience.
Enterprise.
You don't see color?
I don't see detail.
Your car.
Okay,
Darya.
Hey Jamie.
I'll have a skim.
Listen,
you're the one who I had to go
through five fucking [inaudible].
You're going to do this.
I knew I knew it.
Yeah.
Look,
I know you're busy.
I knew it was really hard and
she figured out and she's like,
um,
she's like,
just give me,
I'm like,
no,
you don't understand.
It's not going to be okay.
And she's like,
it'll be fine.
What?
She wanted my number.
Yeah.
I was just like,
no I can't.
Yeah.
Well publicists are for
the most part annoying.
Twats cause most of them
are a really brutal,
I missed the word Twat.
Yeah,
it's good to hear it anymore.
But my publicist is actually a really
cool guy and my last publicist is actually
a very cold,
no,
I don't like labels.
I just called my publicist like twice.
Yeah.
Twice.
Get me an ass.
Where am I supposed to go at 10.
Hey,
twice daily show.
Come on and watch.
Set it up.
Is this not the daily show?
Not Anymore.
Oh,
really?
Hung over shit.
I am,
uh,
I don't drink much,
but I will drink.
I don't drink every day.
That's what you're saying.
Is that how you're rocking it?
No,
I can't.
I have to like schedule when
I can drink Jack Daniels.
Or are you just an beer or,
I do like,
like the feeling of being a little buzzed.
Just so bad for your body though.
I hadn't drank before last night for a
while because I was getting ready for
Shit.
Getting Ready,
getting ready to shut your show.
It was on comedy central when tonight.
What's it called?
Inside Amy Schumer.
Amy Schumer.
But that was already used by someone else.
I want it to be called come
inside with Amy Schumer,
but comedy central.
Liz Phair song,
hot white.
It's like one of the greatest songs ever.
There's nothing wrong with an ode to come.
What are you talking about?
Yeah,
it is.
It's fucking great.
It's a great song.
Really never heard it.
These are blurred out.
Was it really [inaudible]
out of a gang bang
and I'm like,
wait,
why are you so cool with believing
what Whitney
was telling me?
Some of this stuff that you
guys wrote together and stuff.
He was,
yeah,
he's awesome.
But he was saying how
you have a really good,
uh,
being able to like fuck with yourself.
Oh yeah.
He's like a,
he's like,
you're just not my type.
And then this guy tells me he
has aids on her third date.
Are you,
uh,
are you enjoying the process?
Like tell us what's making a show.
It was so much work
being a comic.
I thought that was a lot of work.
This is like ridiculous fucking
difference if you get another season.
And I'm like,
uh,
when I slit my wrists I'm like,
I'm so tired.
Or would you rather just do stand up?
I mean,
I don't know.
Does that work?
That much work?
It is a lot of work to do a show.
I like really like the
show we made though.
But it's so much fun to just to stand up,
isn't it?
It's your own show though.
I'm proud of this shit.
That's awesome.
But I just feel like I
have nothing left in me.
I'm like,
all right,
well well isn't that why you do a,
so you know,
you do.
I'm,
and then you take some time
off and go to The Bahamas.
Can you picture taken
by in your underwear?
Oops.
I didn't know the photographer
that I paid was there.
Why am I in my underwear in the cause.
You want to get some press?
That would not be smart for me,
Dude.
Bro,
you're so wrong.
Listen,
you need to what Tyler Durden do and
I just have like my leg over my head
in front of your iPhone.
A couple fingers.
Just do a vine myself.
Like a bowling ball on this yourself.
Like with the camera right there.
I really don't think that that would,
I think that would help me.
It would help you.
That would help me.
You're a comic.
You're not some failure.
Some chick that's on the view.
Our Chelsea,
I've been,
I just guest hosted the VA out of duty.
Are you serious?
That's hilarious.
Is that crazy?
A white lady still on fucking
wants to stockpile ammo.
I'm just kidding.
What's her name?
The pretty blonde lady.
Yeah,
she's hilarious.
I love how she yells when
she's in an argument.
That's the best part.
She yells ports angry.
She just yells or point.
I wonder if they're booking me more now
and wonder if I'll ever get into it with
anyone.
I mean,
I just want to do a good job.
Listen,
you haven't gotten into it
without Elizabeth Chick yet?
No.
Are you being nice or something?
Come on.
She's must've said something that
makes you want to like go whoop.
No,
I agree with all of her views and I have
the same views including your fears are
Mexicans,
Mexicans.
What are the ones who
live in Miami called?
Those are the best Mexicans.
I don't really like any other ones.
God,
listen,
this place feels like Mexico.
This spot we're at.
Just like the decorations like Mexico.
Where the fuck you been in Mexico?
Walls.
Dead animal skulls.
This is like home.
This is like spring break.
This is where I stay in Cancun.
Did you see that video
on the Mexican drug?
Lord cutting his girlfriend set off.
Oh,
it was on.
Showed it.
It show the cutting it off.
Yeah,
with a knife.
It was on youtube.
He got pulled off.
I think still.
I'm like,
why they pull it off?
No,
no,
no.
I don't want to watch it.
It's super graphic.
Yeah.
He holds her head up to
the camera and everything.
My point is Mexico is fucking crazy.
It is not going to Mexico.
Do you ever watch,
I survived where they kidnapped the
guy in Mexico and they keep him,
hold him for ransom.
Is that as a
year?
And they just make them like they shoot
him and they just make him sit in his
own piss and shit and they'd
sleep deprivation is the thing.
Woo.
They play that loud music.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You don't want your kid to have to,
Mexico really must hurt tourism.
Just the lid on.
It's like,
oh,
but you might die.
You might not live.
Yeah.
I mean,
people don't want
to go to Afghanistan.
Okay,
look at it this way.
Yeah.
It all,
I can't,
I don't want to go to Afghanistan.
You're way more likely to get shot in
Mexico than you are in Afghanistan.
The amount of American troops that have
died in Afghanistan is not nearly the
number of people that have been
killed in the drug war in Mexico.
Really?
Oh yeah,
it's way more.
It's way more.
It's like 10 times more
or something crazy.
Yeah.
And nobody's like taking
Christmas to go to,
if you're partying in Juarez,
you fucked up.
That sounds like a guy.
Give your down having it
Amy Schumer away in Juarez.
That dude will fucking bug out
being vantage.
There's gotta be some sort of a solution,
but I don't know what the
fuck it's going to be.
You know,
like,
let's just never go to Mexico.
Well,
it's like,
there's been times in
human history where w,
you know,
civilizations crumbled and
we're essentially watching
that happen in Mexico.
We're watching our neighbor [inaudible]
humbling roiled in this ridiculous war
where the drug dealers have billions of
dollars in tanks and fucking weapons and
shit,
and they hire mercenaries
to come over there.
Is it mostly the border towns?
Yes.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's all quarterly lane.
I don't know where,
you know,
they killed a bunch of
people in Aqua Polo,
Carl,
so I don't think there's a photo in a,
in a fucking resort.
They wonder a resort and
killed a bunch of foreigners.
Ah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Poor really bad.
Oh,
it's bad.
They're touching the way
it was actually no from
Bain.
There were still silly
enough to go to acapulco.
Well,
you know,
they deserve it using this Lillian lists.
That's just unacceptable.
I don't know what happened.
I don't know who it was.
I don't know what the story was,
but I know that it's,
you know,
the,
especially the border towns,
they're incredibly dangerous.
Yeah.
I mean it's just people going down left
and right and getting know headless
fucking body
and it's not like it was safe before.
No,
no safe place.
Yeah.
It's interesting when a culture like
drastically changes over a fairly short
period of time.
I used to go to Mexico and we just go
straight to the spring break thing on TV
in like the late nineties you know,
maybe like name names,
like maybe even the early two
thousands it was like no big deal.
Yeah.
What was it like the grind.
The grind.
Yeah.
Maybe you and Eric were on the ground.
I remember we used to get
our pump on you this week.
Told me how to shave my chest.
I believe all of this.
Sure.
Yeah.
Were dance partners.
We're going to be the first gay
couple on dances with the stars.
You guys fuck each other?
Just to be honest with you.
For how long?
Like an hour or I could watch
that longer than the head cutting.
What'd you write?
You Watch two guys.
Fuck.
Easier than it had never seen two guys.
Yeah,
I find that hard to believe why mean
in real life or on the Internet.
I've never even watched
it on the Internet.
Pull it up for Brian.
I'm not,
I'm not.
All right.
That was hard to convince me.
No.
Okay.
Brian,
the only way this is gonna work.
Take the monitor
and um,
don't scream.
Don't scream the show.
And then on that screen over there,
you need to show two guys
fucking just for Amy.
So well,
it will never show.
You can do that,
right?
The guys,
I want it to be fine.
He's going to find that
mix has to flesh best to flesh.
I actually invented that name.
The guy's name is flash
mixed master six master flesh
by accident.
Yeah,
right.
Just fucks everybody
who shows up and slings.
Dick,
my name is cheese cream.
Can I get a rap name?
Well,
my rap name be.
I always felt like if we're
going to have a nickname,
can't really nickname yourself.
Knowing someone tried to
push their own nickname,
they introduce you as their nicknames.
Fuck
my volleyball team.
It didn't really catch on shrooms the for
made your own nickname up.
It means you have no friends.
That's the only thing it means.
Yeah,
it doesn't make any sense other
than that crazy pub Fred's person.
Hey guys,
I'm going to be t rex.
You know,
cause I'm always talking like this.
Yeah,
fighters.
It's hilarious.
Fighters come up with some
of the silliest nickname.
They have to stick with it
and it's there forever.
Change like a Rory Macdonald,
he used to call himself the water
boy and then he changed his to Aries,
Aries,
God of war.
That's kind of interesting where you're
allowed to change your name change,
but now I feel more like the god of war,
the world,
the god of war.
It relates to like Mexico crumbling.
I'm reading this.
I'm listening rather to this podcast
that explains what the fuck is wrong with
the Middle East.
One of the reasons why the Middle
East is so backwards and fucked up.
His Gingiss Khan,
Genghis Khan rolled through
there in 1200 something.
It wasn't gangs.
It was actually his sons because he
was already dead and crushed Baghdad
killing.
They might've killed a million people.
Is that people fucking gay guys talking
to elderly fat guys.
Fucking
take it away.
That's not cool.
We're not going to get an honest reaction.
As long as she's seen it.
Now we can say that we were the first.
Oh,
she's looking right at it right now.
Okay.
Put it away.
We're good.
No,
no,
no.
That's enough.
There's 69 they're
blowing each other like two gentlemen.
Who Cares?
I call him.
I'll fucking,
yeah,
I don't know.
I,
you know what?
I didn't see them penetrating each other.
That might've been a different vibe,
but I didn't mind the
69 you've got to prove,
see the accurate fucking right there.
Clearly.
I thought it was going to bum me out,
but yeah,
fuck him.
That's okay.
There you go.
Well thank you guys.
We got to do this together.
You're welcome.
The cons rolled,
the Mongols rolled through Baghdad and
the 12 hundreds and killed everybody.
Apparently Baghdad was
at one point in time,
like the most advanced city in the world,
like their science,
their literature,
their approach or in Islam itself was
responsible initially for like all sorts
of like scientific and literary advances.
And it was like a booming
like intellectual city and
Gingiss con like sent the
guy or the what?
The con it wasn't Gaviscon.
Yeah,
Iraqi soccer con and we rocking this all
when one to sent this guy a some sort
of a letter,
he sent a letter back.
They didn't like each other.
So the Mongols just came in
and storm the city for weeks.
They just,
they would,
they would hurl human
fat that was on fire.
They would kill people and light them
on fire and then it hurl it with like a
catechol.
So with slam onto the roofs
and start houses on fire.
Cause apparently human fat burns
really good for a long time.
Ah Dude.
They would just flay fat off people and
like fill up catapults with it and light
it on fire.
They worked fucking crazy.
These,
these stories of what they did,
they killed everybody.
Now they killed as many as
2 million people in Baghdad.
It was his little as a hundred
thousand or as many as 2 million.
It's really hard to tell from those days,
but essentially it was
everyone who lived there.
Most historians claim was around 800,000
which is an insane amount and the
amount of humans they killed,
all these people lit everything on fire,
broke,
all anything that was made that was any,
any advancements,
but through all the writing in the water
and killed all the people that were
there killed everyone they said to the
river actually was black from the ink of
the books that they had thrown in,
destroyed all the writing and knowledge
hundreds and hundreds of years because
they're the Mongols.
They don't give a fuck the Mongols
where it should have good kingus Khan.
Genghis Khan himself is responsible
for as many as 70 deaths,
70 million deaths,
70 million.
Geez.
Like him and the Mongols and his,
his invasions and his conquering
different parts of the world.
They,
they're responsible for as
many as 70 million death.
Jesus.
Brian.
Like what we think about like,
like Hitler layer didn't have shit on
this motherfucker cause this guy did it
all at a horse.
Okay.
Does up the Annie?
Yes.
He killed 70 million people
on horseback and kill.
Kill more than 20 million.
It's quite
a few.
Really?
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
They all killed a lot of people.
I've killed no one.
What about you guys?
I'm at zero,
right?
Yeah.
You're not much of a conqueror.
A couple of dogs and I was little.
It's hard to wrap your head
around that kind of money,
man.
He kneeled on durable.
Yeah.
Dead
terrible blood was on my knee.
My mom didn't want us to get away so we
just put it in an empty tub and we were
hanging out with the new terrible
and I nailed that and they killed it.
That's a wrap.
That's more depressing than the 70
million dead people in Baghdad or the head
shopping.
You're like,
wow,
Amy,
a way to bring it down.
Oh,
okay.
I thought we were just showing the sodomy
so lucky that there's no Gingiss con
today.
It seems like it's just luck
when someone like that comes along.
It's like Dan Carlin is a name for him.
He calls them historical arsonists.
But like there's a very rare that
you get an Alexander the Great,
or you get a Gig as are
you getting Napoleon,
you know,
or Cesar.
Why when these guys come along,
they just wreck shop for like 50 60
world change the world in 50 or 60 years.
The God killed 70 million.
So you've got a drastic change in politics
and people say never again campaign
like a,
we did like the fruit juice.
The Muslims went into China.
They said they killed anyone.
I don't want to forget.
They didn't know they killed everyone.
They did.
They didn't care.
Kill everyone.
They would leave and then come back in
three days and kill everyone they missed.
Oh,
like people that were hiding him because
they knew that people would hide.
So I told my dad and the Israeli army,
they told them somebody threw a grenade
into kindergarten once they found out
which village was from.
I said kill everything moving.
Oh my God.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
They said that the,
the um,
the Muslims had taken a,
um,
a,
a crew to go into China for the first
time to see what China was all about.
Cause they heard all these rumors about
how much money enriches were in China
and they had a gigantic army and the
Caribbean Shaw and they were going to go
in,
they were going to like,
like they were eventually
going to invade China
when they got their Christmas shows,
me and Sha say,
w boom.
So when they go there,
they just saw
these white peaks in the background
that they thought were snow covered
mountains that were
actually mountains of bones
because in this time in this town,
this is one town,
they killed 2 million people
and there's one area in China.
The Mongols came in and killed everybody.
Like,
we don't even understand what this kind
of carnage must have been like when you
talking about 1200 and
when you think about today,
like there's no group of humans that
everyone's a murderer and psychopath.
Like you got thousand serial killers.
They're not organized serial killers.
Like look at al Qaeda.
I mean how many people were going
out kind everyone's Terrell.
Fred.
I tried it.
Was it 30 dudes that are fucking crazy?
I was Osama bin Laden.
They killed and he was living
with six people in the country.
At least serious raised entire cities.
Just put,
taking boulders.
This is like your younger years ago.
Wait,
what city?
I was in high school.
Uh,
I dunno when I was in high school.
I was thinking of saying I started but
that's the guy who pulled those and
killed,
they killed everybody in the city
cause everybody cause they protested.
Wow.
Destroy the city.
How many people?
I Dunno.
Wow.
But it a lot like thousands.
Thousands of people.
Oh Wow.
This is while it's still a high school.
Yeah.
Well let's don't let it get out.
And coincidentally,
what part of the world is it?
The same?
Yeah,
same part of the world.
So he left so left people there.
This is what happened to rape and
get the genetics when he came.
Oh,
they raped ever.
All the women,
they say that in one part
of the world and that Asia,
that part of the world,
more than 5% of the people that
live there have gang has cons.
Um,
them.
Yeah,
I think it's 5% I might have made
that at home or out of his own.
Please do your own Google search.
Right?
So game of Thrones.
Yeah.
But this guy,
no,
he's way crazier than game of Thrones.
This,
this is the craziest guy in human history.
Yeah.
Like everybody wants to talk about Hitler.
Genghis Khan was way crazier than Hitler.
They would storm into towns and just
kill everything out of the blue babies,
women,
children,
rape,
kill everything.
Kill everybody.
They would take people and cut their
skin off and force feed it to them until
they died.
They would do on skin.
Yeah.
They do the,
they,
they killed people and yeah.
What have you met her if they
were eating somebody else's skin?
Some of the low,
I think I might rather eat my own skin.
Then a stranger he would send
like even you and I know you.
I think I'd probably still rather get my,
my Mayan skin.
He looks delicious.
Oh,
he does?
Like he's,
Oh,
please.
He's adorable.
What about
guy though?
Fuck.
I would be very tender
that you barely knew.
Yeah.
What about fat woman?
I'd be more tender.
No,
I can't eat a family.
Yeah,
you'd be filled with like a cigarette.
He tastes,
yeah.
Ah,
that's smoked.
Smoked flavor.
You might be right.
That might sort of help this.
You don't know til you try it.
Yeah.
Brian cut off some skin.
Okay.
Yeah.
If we were to cook one of us,
I would want to cook.
You me?
Yeah.
Why?
Most muscle?
No,
I just went on my instinct.
What do,
what do you think?
Yeah,
I was going to say
Brian for for most meat,
but I don't know what makes
most meet tough to chew on.
I know,
I know.
I think it would be good.
Definitely want to be Jamie because
he's the one that he's doing this.
How is this?
Sure,
Dan,
this.
Yeah,
if you had to,
if you had to a,
if you will like trapped,
uh,
in like one of those a Yukon things where
you got to eat someone university of
Connecticut.
No,
no.
Oh right.
That makes more sense.
Don't kill people in Connecticut.
Need them.
Why they're so boring.
If it was like the Donner party,
there was a couple when we were traveling
from north,
that was from Connecticut and you could
see these motherfuckers from a mile away
and Joey Diaz and I would look
at him and I actually said,
I go,
I go look at these
Connecticut white people.
I go look at them like that.
I think you could just tell.
And he goes,
he goes,
how can you tell?
And I go,
look at the kids' shoes.
The kid was wearing boat shoes.
Oh boy.
A young boy,
he was like 10.
And he's wearing boat shoes with shorts,
with a belt on Beltane shorts.
They don't grow up around enough black
people that they have fear in them.
So they just do whatever they want.
It's like no Portland,
they're missing character.
No,
it's worse than Portland.
Way Worse Portland's way better
than Connecticut and Connecticut.
You have all these like weird rich dads
that had been stealing money in the
stock market the whole life and they pay
for these kids to go to private schools
where they all stare at each other cause
no one's getting any education at home
because your mom's on pills and her face
can't move cause she shot botox into it
and she's fucking Disney all day cause
she's got a Xanax addiction and all of
you to stare at each other.
Just handled little whales on them
cause you think your alternative.
But really you're just a
rich little piece of shit.
You have a crest on your,
you're crazy and you're going to start
fucking your male friends just cause
you're so bored from your weight and
title life and your wife hates you.
They were all traveling together.
This,
this woman didn't understand why
she had to take her shoes off.
It was hilarious.
They were telling us
where this bitch has been living,
but she goes,
my shoes are open toed.
You can see my feet and like,
you have to take your shoes off.
I belonged to equinox.
Do you understand?
It's like literally
arguing with her husband.
She's like,
it's open toed.
I think you can wear
them over their husband.
Like,
what's he going to do fucker in the face
or at least passes out and
just wakes up a learned person.
Well,
I can't do that again.
Uh,
he was tired at that point.
Oh,
we ain't breakfast.
It was about to crash dog.
I'm like,
God,
him in Connecticut.
I'd like to see while
we were in Jersey too,
which is the,
it's,
you know,
it was a,
it was Connecticut.
People in Jersey and Joey
are going to Phoenix.
Oh,
you're doing that?
Two of us at night by night.
Thursday night.
Please come on that week.
The two of you come down that
week and we'll blow it up.
Oh,
it's next week.
Okay.
Come on.
Come on next week.
Tomorrow.
Are you guys going to be here?
Okay.
Yeah,
let's blow it up.
That's right.
It's may already.
Do you love it?
It's fun.
It was just like,
just turned April.
Wait,
what fuck is going on?
This winter was a joke.
It was because we don't really have a
winter bad New York sucked to this winter.
I,
Hey,
the weather,
you know what he's like decided
that la people are too shallow.
That's how you feel judged.
What happened?
And he's tired of bad about,
uh,
about the business out here.
New stages is good and you know,
a new people,
new experiences,
experience.
Well comics to watch,
you know,
new styles of comedy.
Oh,
that goes into my train of thought.
I want to go,
here's my theory.
A little bit of like 5% once a day
to a black check for like two months.
Harlem shake.
Yeah.
Here's another party.
You marrying a black church and after
the black chick doesn't work out,
it will get the Julius.
Oh,
he married your mom.
You Shit your pants again.
I'm not cleaning this.
You mind if I introduced Mike,
that girlfriend to you?
I would just be ashamed.
I'm like,
here's my girlfriend,
a viva.
Viva.
What happened?
Bam
tapped out.
It's named after hand sanitizer.
Yeah,
you found it.
Yeah.
That's not good.
Have you ever got that lecture?
No.
Shit.
Oh,
I'm going to and uh,
I know some of the black guy.
We should push it.
I have it set up earlier.
I don't know.
You have it set up like you said.
Hey listen,
what a fuck.
A black chick and you're black chick.
So what's the secret?
It's a secret secret to the world.
He did.
He used a secret.
Smart.
That's a beautiful thing.
That secret.
It really seems to weed.
That'd be funny if you're inside
of a house and a family like you,
just secret like a huge black cock guide
was the Black Hawk sit like 10 minutes
and meditate guys visit.
So one day,
one day a guy breaks into your
house at the exact moment he's here.
How racist.
I just assume that a guy would
have to break in your house.
Really funny.
Really funny to picture a Connecticut
woman sitting in her home like,
oh,
you made it.
And like she thinks this
guy is going gonna fuck her.
And he robs her.
That's great clubs or over the head.
That's great.
Cut your finger off to get her rank
cause it's stuck on that thing cause she
doesn't ever take it off
cause she's embarrassing.
Meant that she floated,
she did our finger washes,
eats everything.
Whenever you can't take it off
and blood diamond on her thing,
she has to hack it off with a chainsaw.
Hey,
there's no way.
It just won't do it.
Not Quick enough.
Meanwhile,
she just wants to Black Hawk.
He didn't even know that
we're giving it to her,
but he's going to take her shit.
Awesome.
Didn't go fantasy and then be like,
oh it's been working out
at all the way I want.
Isn't it funny how that would
be horrific for one person,
but yet another chicken?
Yes.
Yeah.
He'd be like,
Oh this is my fucking day.
Yeah.
Finally some gangster Dick.
It's do it.
If you don't,
you don't.
With black blackjack.
If you,
I've never been with a black check.
One,
two,
three white so far.
But um,
I,
you know,
I hope to branch out.
Yes.
What about like any of the,
uh,
alternative races?
I've been Asians,
the FMLA,
I would,
I'm open to whatever I,
yeah,
sure.
No,
I think if you've never dealt
with anything but white.
Yeah,
no way.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
First of all,
why would you assume she has this
such an extensive sexual background?
Because of her act?
She's a cat.
She seems like the type of cow that
guy sits a fucking gets to know her.
Any hangs out for a while.
Jesus.
Whoa.
She wouldn't have a bunch of different
relationships if I want to sleep with
someone and happens real quick.
Like within an hours.
Yeah.
Well there's nothing wrong with that.
I Know
Ryan and I were talking yesterday about
the different girls that we dated for
like like a long time ago.
Windup slept with him the first
day [inaudible] relationship,
but yet to use it as a bargaining chip.
It's just like,
yeah,
well,
you know what?
That's because you don't
have anything else to offer.
That's usually what that's all about.
Or maybe I've friends that just seriously
aren't ready and they need to really
trust someone,
but if I physically am drawn to
somebody and I want to sleep with them,
I gone wrong with that.
There's nothing wrong with that.
There were,
the problem with that is it too many
people in the world are assholes and so
that doesn't work out well because every
now and then you fucking asshole and
then you've got an ass hole in your life.
You're like,
ah,
yeah,
she got to know this person better for,
you're right.
Then then you're done with them.
Get to know them like you
introduced them again.
You have sex with him again and again,
and then you start hanging out with them.
You get to know him.
Then you go,
oh,
okay,
I should have got to know you better
because I'm not really into your
personality.
Right.
I would rather have known what a piece
of shit you are because that's the worst,
like chicks getting dressed and she
tells a nigger joke and you're like,
oh,
oh wow.
Christ.
What wasn't even looking for reactions.
You were saying it casually
and unapologetically.
Yeah.
He's like,
you know,
they are.
You're like,
oh,
okay.
Not,
let's take away the plan to meet.
My parents had sort of already blown them
because then at least you can get that
in.
You can't do it after.
You know that.
That's a good point for a guy,
but not for the girl.
I Dunno.
For girls,
not such a good point,
but I mean sometimes you sleep with
someone as a girl and you're not,
you're not interested in
building something with them.
They just want some sick.
Yeah,
that person's Day.
Yeah.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Does absolutely nothing wrong with that.
I feel okay about it.
The problem is it's too many people that
will let you think did something wrong
with that because they
actually want to fuck you.
You know?
Especially girls,
girls take so much grief from guys that
really were attracted them like fucking
whore.
She's just fucking whore.
It's kind of gross,
right?
You guys,
because they're weak.
They're weak.
Bitch ass bodies don't realize that
terrible feeling that they're having about
this person is discussed.
It's really just rejection,
rejection.
The fact they were ignored.
You know who else does that?
Other girls,
those,
those that say,
you know what happened,
but with the Ohio case,
that's Steubenville coast with a girl
was being dragged like other girls are
calling her a slut.
Oh,
makes me so mad.
I did nothing to help that one graphic.
That's terrific.
And I can't say the same thing at
their competitive nature or something.
Wow.
The thing about Amy talking about
chicks wanted to kill themselves in the
elevator or each other.
That's how you paraphrase.
It doesn't work.
That's why I can't trust the member.
When Amy,
she wanted to throw herself
down an elevator shaft on,
no,
I didn't use my own
pitches with elevators.
I wait.
Hold on a minute.
I don't think I said that.
Yeah,
that's doable.
Thing was really upset,
really was,
well,
what is that?
Is that the family?
Is it the people not talking to people
about the opposite sex being human
culture,
whole high school.
It wasn't just one family.
Yeah,
you're right.
Not only the high school,
it was actually the adults because they
were hiding it because they didn't want
it to fuck up the high school.
It really is like crazy.
It's everybody in the community
making these guys feel invincible and
untouchable and you can do whatever you
want your gods right now you're got so
crazy and I was his girl just really drunk
and no one did anything to help her.
Ooh,
Jesus Christ.
That's a ooh
human nature.
It's not like about this
one coach and do anything.
You know Lars von Trier movies that
I think about that all the time,
like just if,
if humans are given the chance
they will become complete monsters.
I think that's probably true.
It's certainly possible.
It's not fun to think about,
well,
look at this fucking Mongol
thing we were talking about,
there was not even a thousand years ago.
This is,
this is heart of darkness is every movie.
It's all about like if you take away
society back to animals and more terrified
of that.
I mean we're all tear up.
That's where my,
these,
the mad max movies and Zombie movies is
essentially the breakdown of society are
terrified of women
were just saying about that girl.
Like everyone,
the girls are scared.
Like if I side with her then the
guys are going to turn on me.
And it's like,
and I think in the Muslim side,
the way they like cover
yourself and you know,
it's like people have this fear and people
get upset about somebody saying like,
yeah,
I'll sleep with someone when I want to
somehow can make a failed castrate it for
some reason that I would
maybe make my own choice.
And I think that uh,
it's being raised by week bitches too
when he's growing up that
not every woman he likes,
it's going to like him.
And you got to realize that it's
not their position to like you.
You have to suck it up and either
improve yourself as a person,
get away your whatever deficits or find
someone who does like you gotta be worth
something.
You have to actually have value.
You have to be fun to be around.
You have to be enjoyable to talk to.
But people don't think
that in the beginning.
They just want you to like them.
Especially like spoiled people.
We know like spoiled Shitty
dudes who like their dad.
Like they can do no wrong.
These kids,
they show up and they're fucking assholes.
It
is guys and girls versions.
I mean let's just call
a spade a spade here.
Well this is what this
guy was talking about.
This is why it's fascinating.
The Mongol thing,
because he said when Baghdad was raided
by the Mongols and they crushed the
society,
they basically started from scratch after
that with the people that were in the
outskirts.
I mean that is literally
what happened with Baghdad.
They had a repopulate
Baghdad rebuild everything.
He killed everyone and through all the
literature away so that they see that
today they're just getting to the point
like culturally of where they were in
2012 and I bet a lot of
those people were like,
let's not go in right away to the city.
Let's wait another three days.
Yeah.
But it's also like the
distrust and like they were,
I started reading about it after listening
to this cause it's so interesting.
I was like there's this people that equate
the whole distrust of foreigners and
the outside world to being invaded by
the Mongols that apparently the Muslim
religion and Islamic culture was
completely different back then.
And it was like the Greeks,
it was like the Romans.
It was like people that were like,
you know,
actively trying to pursue education
and enrichment and science.
It was a completely different type
of culture or either where they,
I mean they thought they
had the greater army,
the,
the walls too.
They thought they had the greater army,
but they didn't understand
how gangster the Mongols are.
The Mongols were throwing trees at them.
They cut all their trees down.
They took two weeks,
they cut all their trees down everywhere,
all around the city.
And then they stack them up with giant
catapult and hurled them over the gates
destroying everything in the city.
So imagine Taylor,
the Hobbit,
12 a d and you're sitting
there full size palm trees,
whirling or destroying mosques.
And they did this,
by the way,
for two weeks before they
started to go in just launching,
launching fiery shit at them,
launching,
launching things,
raw,
launching rocks.
They collected rocks,
launching them into the city.
So they basically over the walls,
everything's getting pulverized,
everything's getting crushed that can't
go outside the gates cause they keep,
they can't get more food,
they can't get anything.
And these motherfuckers,
these crazy savage barbarian sociopath's
on horses with each guy at a horse.
And then they had nine extra horses.
So there's hundreds of thousands of
animals and people outside your gates and
they're hurling trees at you
just waiting for you to give up.
And everything's on fire.
Everything's on fire,
everyone's dying in front of you.
And then boom,
they come in and when they come in they
just cut down everyone running through
the streets,
cutting people in half
everybody they find dead.
Everybody hiding dead.
Everybody in any mosque dead just
come in chopping heads off dead.
And they,
they would do this and they
would completely clean out
an entire area like they
changed entire course of human history.
They weren't,
they weren't looking to take survivors,
survivors.
If they took survivors,
it was only because they were at war with
someone else and what they would do is
take the survivors and put them in the
front lines and use them oftentimes as
the the front who would push an army into
the town and people would be shooting
arrows at their own friends because their
own friends would be forced to be at
the front line of this army behind them.
They would see the Mongols on their horses
and these people would have thousands
and thousands of people just be
forced through the door of a,
of,
of a,
of the gate of a,
of a city.
Sure was insane times,
man,
I love this stuff.
Oh Man.
It's incredible.
It's just so fascinating to know.
I am.
I love watching the broad spectrum of
people in this life that we encounter,
but this is this,
this life.
It's so interesting to see that people
just like you and I were living in that
world.
It's like it's,
it's just,
it's the same species,
the exact same species as you and I
are dealing with all over the world.
It's just,
it was a thousand years ago.
It's the same thing.
I think we would have been
bad ass is then you would
have been dead or rate.
We'll like,
do you have an extra leading up to
all leading up to my rape and yes,
of course I do.
How good am I gone on one to 10
my voice is a 12 and you know it.
So they kept you around and then what?
You would have become
more than Gingiss cons.
Wives.
All right.
You could be the funny wife.
I'd be like,
you guys did.
Have you heard this one?
Remember when he killed
that first 30 million?
Well listen to this one.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Yeah,
it'd be good to have in Washington.
We're just so lucky.
We live in the the e everybody's on phone.
Yeah,
this guy does suck.
I mean the world does suck.
I mean,
there are things that happen like
in Boston when these two assholes,
but there's not 100,000 of 'em
on horses storming into Boston
telling everyone you ever heard that Mel
Gibson movie showing everybody made was
wasn't innovation Apocalypto yeah,
with all the Gringo get the Gringo,
the beaver,
the beaver beaver,
they shot and then he went
crazy and they're like,
fuck,
what are we going to do with this?
Well,
they had to know he was crazy
when they're shooting that and,
but I didn't know if he would go bullshit.
This shit over there
hadn't gotten out earlier.
They should,
I guess it had celebrities are
protected while he had that one,
a shadow where the cops pulled them
over when he started ranting about Jews,
I'm not going to do,
oh,
we were all like,
yeah,
we kind of see that.
That's the sign of a real
crazy person when you don't,
if you're getting racist,
but straight to Jews,
that's like,
that's true.
I mean,
that's not just like you're skipping over,
you know,
but even though you're a Jew,
I fucking agree with you.
Yeah,
absolutely true.
You know,
people might discount that
because of the of your,
your Judaism.
Judaism.
I think it's true though.
It's so true.
What is something about the conspiracy
folks who've always go Jew build a
burger,
let's build a burger.
The badges out controlling
the world's economy.
You don't even know.
I don't know,
like build a bear,
but with hamburgers.
Yeah.
Not Build a bear for the Burger.
That's a good idea for you.
Build a burger.
Like make it look like a bank
would take over an old bank
and turn into a burger place where you
build a burger and everybody wears like
fucking Richard Nixon masks and all that.
No,
no.
Look,
look,
look like you're in a cult.
Do you,
um,
did you ever hear Bohemian Grove?
Do you know this real thing
that they actually do?
Really interesting.
We're all the world's top like
financers and bankers and world leaders.
People from all over the world.
Like the Bush family's been going to
this place forever and they know it's
called.
It's called,
um,
well the,
it's called Bohemian Grove and the APP,
the thing that worship is called Molek
and Molek is this our God and they burn
a,
they have a sacrifice.
They burned in effigy.
Like Alex Jones is crazy.
We all know the Alex Jones is crazy.
He's a fascinating dude.
You know,
he believes that it
conspiracy and everything,
but he actually snuck in and got video
footage of these fucking rituals these
people do.
So you're having all these world
leaders and they're wearing robes.
Alex Jones slipping.
Not even one of his guys.
They didn't know who he was back then.
He was,
he was nobody back then.
And I think he actually got caught.
I know if he got caught,
he saw them all like Brooke doin well,
they had hidden camera footage of these
fucking people going through this uh,
this ritual.
And it's like these people
there are there weird fuckers,
man.
Yeah,
they really do do weird shit.
That's like conspiracy theory shit.
Like,
like the skull and crossbones.
That's real.
It's really weird.
Yeah.
Like the juicy Kubrick's eyes wide shut.
Yes.
Apparently that's like based on real
things that some of these weird groups do.
Oh really?
Yeah,
they're just so rich and
board all do Kabbalah.
Also
the type of checks that
you can bang it off.
You're in one of those
mass parties in Greenwich,
Connecticut.
Oh my God.
Are we going to get a 32 year olds?
Gigantic fucking huge ballroom.
That's actually a part of some guys manner
and you all show up and give the keys
to the Valet and put your mask on.
Especially because if they really
are complicit in some shady shit,
whether it's they're doing like scams
and stealing money or whatever the fuck
they're doing,
you're going to want the person
who's with you to like to be all in,
you know?
And if you,
you know that you like their waste swap
in and you're part of some crazy group
like you're,
you're,
you guys are fucking each other.
Yeah.
I mean you guys are living you.
Everyone's living in this crazy,
you know,
you're going home power on me.
You want to fuck your friends
wives that to fuck your friend.
Well don't they always.
Whenever someone,
when they're trying to get
people into elite groups,
they always like make you do
shit that you don't want to do.
Like that's a big part
from the crips to rich.
Well it's like,
yeah,
if you want to be a part of a group,
you got to sacrifice,
you get something,
you got to prove you're down while we're
to shoot somebody just because they're
flush your lights at me just do it.
Does that thing in game of Thrones
where the Khaleesi is like she gets,
she gets this army and they all
to be a part of this elite army.
They all had to kill a baby
in front of its mother.
But that's like standard shit.
Like throughout history,
you're going to be a
part of some crazy group.
You got to do something nutty.
So these people that are like fucking
rig in the economy and stealing billions
of dollars like these east Hampton cunts,
I wanna just go to one of those parties.
I just want to see a dragon.
Like there's a part of me was like,
I bet there's a drawing in some
way or do you think there's a drag?
Dragons used to exist?
Like why are there so many
dragons in human culture?
Oh,
I hope so.
God.
Yeah,
cause it was dragons.
Not just in China,
but there's dragons in
Europe at the same time.
I think they were dragons.
Look,
I'm not some return.
I don't think they were Unicorns,
but there were,
right.
Yeah,
I know.
Do you think they breathe
fire or is that just a breath?
No,
they breathe fire.
Well,
the Komodo dragons,
those are nuts.
Maybe because Komodo dragons,
if they bite you,
even if you survive,
like you're going to die from the saliva.
The toilet.
Yeah.
Massive.
They have a botulism in their saliva.
Yeah.
They were just,
their mouths are fucking the worst.
Just festering bacteria.
I think you'd probably run fasten you.
Yeah.
They're the biggest
lizard on earth next to,
I think they're actually even
bigger.
The Harker picture yourself,
Bob.
We can,
we'd get behind a tree.
What?
I catch them around corners.
It's like,
and you don't make your
songs the sooner the Lizard.
Yeah.
Bigger.
But aren't they bigger than,
so how has the Komodo
dragon the biggest drag?
The biggest lizard?
I don't know.
Are they bigger than crocodiles?
I think so.
Can you guys watch my
television show tonight?
Fuck yeah.
Bitch.
10 30 and comedy Central Police Watch it.
Um,
and it's called inside Amy Schumer.
Amy Schumer.
This is what he said that
he had me laughing when
you're all doing a spy scene.
Wow.
Oh,
the shows,
they always like the
guys get to do cool shit.
And the girls are always like,
all right,
and you just have to suck his dick.
So here's what we're
doing with the mission.
Yeah.
But where'd you,
everyone had a code name?
Yeah.
It was like all super bad ass.
And then mine was butterflies.
Butterflies.
Creepy eating a deer.
Oh Wow.
That's a Komodo Dragon.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Wipe your mouth.
There are monsters.
Komodo dragons.
Hawkin animal man.
God,
I bet there's some,
I bet it could people
in Connecticut on those.
Oh,
look at this with a,
they're feeding together on a car.
Oh,
that's like walking dead.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like walking dead.
The ones getting over the top when I
looked at it by accident and I want to go
hang on,
just
pulling chunks out of this thing.
It's ruthless fucking animal.
How many babies or shoot,
10 10 episodes.
All done.
Ready?
They're all done.
So you go on vacation
now.
Well that's,
I'm going to put to New
Orleans for a month.
Nice and right.
I ain't getting new new new writing.
We'll get that thing standing up on a
time lags pulling that deer out of a tree.
What if you see that coming out of here?
Maybe they hung it.
So whatever the fuck it is,
maybe they hung it so that people can,
uh,
see it either right away.
And then,
I don't know what I would
do after that fucking day.
Chasing after you did it.
See the thing is,
maybe that's where the
idea of dragon's came from.
Cause they're,
bro,
they like fire and that breath,
but it's really just that they're there.
So live as fucking toxic.
You know,
I feel like they would have
found a bone or something.
Fire-Breathing bone.
Look,
they breathe fire.
Trust me.
Could you imagine if there wasn't an
animal that actually could breathe?
Fire?
God Damn.
Monsanto would copyright it.
They would go here and be like,
it's ours.
Yeah.
They'd be like,
we own it.
And then they would just have fucking
fires and weird cities for no reason.
Like all of a sudden Detroit's on fire.
See Dragons walking through
the fucking streets.
Well,
if you're going to light one city on fire,
that's a good spot.
Oh no,
that's not what I was saying.
Oh,
magic.
I think a crocodile is
technically a reptile.
Yeah.
Don't know what the difference
in reptile and Lizard is.
Think there's a difference.
I think that's why,
because I don't believe that
crocodiles are large or large.
It was a snake.
A snake is a reptile as well.
You know towels.
Crocodiles are reptiles,
so
they just kicked in.
Amy,
we're here for you.
We're giddy because you're,
you're,
you're awesome.
And where around Jim Narcissism.
I will believe that you really mean we,
we were Giddy to have you here.
We're very excited.
Why don't we get to see you
like once a year or something?
Every time I come to la
I ask us to come see you.
Let's try to do things more often.
He did one night
Moontower that the festival in Austin.
Is that a comedy festival?
No.
How's that work?
Is that like south by southwest but
they don't pay for Shit and they just
pay for shit south by
southwest sent me something.
It was hilarious.
We will pay you a hundred no,
no,
no.
It said we will give you a free
pass to go see other shows.
It's worth $1,500.
They price that way cause they give it
out to everybody and they don't give you
a companion pass.
I've thought it was the most
ridiculous shit I've ever heard of it.
It's not cool.
And they end,
the shows are all sold out at south by
southwest and in return they will give
your email address out to everyone.
I have still been getting letters
saying we'd love your band.
I had to beg for hundred
where you'll have your band.
Really,
you get there.
They're like,
can you flyer for this band?
You're like,
why does anybody still do it?
Because it's a cool festival but it's
kind of less go way more like this.
It's a burrito stage now.
It's becoming way more
corporate Rido stage.
Those are delicious.
I listened.
I'm not on Doritos.
I
love the fact they've moved into Taco
bell and started taking over with the cool
ranch.
Great merger.
What a great merge.
Amazing.
And it's always good for you.
So good for you.
People don't know that
you're really good for Ya.
Austin is the fucking shit.
Yes it is.
It's almost worth dealing
with their bullshit just so
you can go on stage there.
I just don't like the idea of them make
a Dunkin made a whole video about it.
Don't get were pull up
Dunkin's video come out.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
Pull up Duncan Trussell
on south by southwest.
Yeah.
Cause he made a whole video about it,
which like really kind of
encapsulated it in a whole area.
So that's how I realized
I was doing it last year.
And then like most show was like,
I was like,
you're not doing,
I thought you were doing south by cause.
No,
I switched on the pages.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
I shouldn't be on that one.
It's not a greedy thing.
It's just like what is justice?
What is the festival about?
It's about art.
Okay.
How come the artists aren't getting paid?
Like who's getting paid?
You're making a salary.
You're making,
are you guys make a profit?
Like how's this work?
People here who've paid to
get in so people paid to
get in and where's the money
go?
Does it go to charity?
It goes to charity.
I kinda get it.
But it's got to all go to charity.
Yeah.
That means you can't get paid either.
They're giving you the salary.
Ah,
no,
not this one.
Not this one.
This has been done a billion times.
Go to the cloud one.
Not this one.
The clown one.
Yeah.
Don't do the fucking Hitler One.
It's so stupid.
It's not even a real Hitler be one thing.
If it was like footage of the
real Hitler getting crazy,
that's like an actor playing Hitler.
The best of all those
were watching him with,
with Jeff Ross.
And so who else are the parking lot?
But although the good folk Hitler on that,
on that scene,
they just resell title ever.
They're crying.
They told me I'd have to pay for my
airfare and hotel and then I wouldn't get
paid to reform.
I decided to call a clown and
offer her as similar deal.
That's really funny.
Yes.
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Yes,
I can hear you.
Hi there.
My name's Melissa with Cranston.
I wanted to find out,
do you ever,
do you ever travel out
of state to perform?
MMM,
I need,
I,
I haven't so far,
but why?
Well,
we are throwing a kids
party out here in Austin,
Texas.
Um,
it's it the Fisher House,
which is a pretty prestigious a
house in the party's going to be.
Well,
it takes a lot of the elites,
Austin elites and all.
We've heard great things about you
on the Internet and we want a clown,
the kid party.
I wanted to see if you'd
be interested in performing
well.
I mean,
hey you,
um,
and you already checked with clown,
like in that area.
We want,
we want you a clown from out of state,
and this is a very prestigious party.
Of course,
we wouldn't be able to pay you or pay
for your airfare or for your lodging,
but we'd love for you to perform
and it'd be great for your resume.
Oh wait,
but you're,
but you wanted me to come in
that and not pay for anything
good
for your crown resume.
Uh,
we want you to come out.
We can't pay for lodging,
airfare or pay you to perform right
now.
I know this is a joke phone call or
something because this is a little funny
because that it,
that it would cost me money to do it.
She's so,
it would be good for your resume.
Okay.
I resume take poop.
We're a party in Austin
when I perform in La.
Well you would be able to meet some,
uh,
there'd be some,
pretty,
pretty well known musicians would are
going to be attending this party and also
we'll be able to give you a couple of
free tickets for shows while you're in
town.
Yeah,
I'm really not interested.
Okay.
Doesn't clean air act the performer to
come all the way there and then not pay.
Why'd you do it though?
Right?
Well if you want to like a real
posts or the year before consider.
Are you done with it now?
You figured it out now.
Yeah,
the cow.
I was going,
if I wanted to go,
just go and just hang it up.
But yeah,
maybe get a guest Bob.
Maybe not like why would
I go there for that?
I would just also what's already
on my resume then your resume.
Oh my God.
Is it on your card?
Have any former weren't even going to
pay you until we found out that you work
for free in Texas.
And we were like,
God Damn Chelsea,
when they had,
they realized they had only
booked one woman or zero women.
It was two years already.
They had,
but they had offered us all,
but we just like couldn't,
nobody took,
okay.
Yeah.
That always gets like
know what they fucking,
they offered it.
Yeah.
They were like,
no,
it was bad press.
Like you have no women's like Oh Fox.
Like to called Chelsea.
Like,
Hey,
can you come down and you go,
yeah,
you're paying me.
I know why you're calling.
Yeah.
And they're like,
fuck fine.
We'll pay you on a stage and age.
Some people she demanded
it and it was like,
yeah,
they have the money.
I don't Larry.
Yes.
That is so funny.
Wow.
That her being like,
but you have other
aren't their local cloud.
That's really what we are.
It's actually a speaking opportunity.
Oh,
your resume.
That's how they look at it.
It really is like just a total,
it's a chance to break as a
musician and south by southwest,
but not as a comedian opportunity man.
Oh that's so funny.
He was a 45 minute discussion and he
can receive a complimentary gold badge,
a $1,350 value.
We will give you an interactive sessions,
events and express.
Yeah.
It was like our rate of one night.
[inaudible] funny actually,
I guess they offered me a
hotel as well as hotel access.
That's a very ambiguous
because I what it means,
it means you get first
in line for a hotel.
They have all these people
that they give hotels too,
but they only have like 200 that means
you're allowed to pay for the hotel.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Hotel access so they can
make sure you get a hotel,
but you pay for it.
Yeah.
Oh that's so cute.
Cool.
That's so hilarious.
Oh my goodness.
People are so fucking crazy.
Yeah,
but Moontower was cool.
It's,
it's an interactive session panel.
I guess it's not even doing standup.
Taking a 2.0 bitch,
you ain't going nowhere.
We locked you in.
We're in the valley.
We are in the valley.
You can't go.
What are you going to go?
You get somewhere better to go.
We got here.
They didn't do a good
bullshit shows.
This is promotion.
This is helping you.
The Amish inside.
Amy Schumer tonight
through live tweeting,
tweet it,
tweet.
I'm like,
he's playing dumb cause
he doesn't want to do it.
No,
he doesn't really do tweet.
It really is retarded.
But you know where he does.
He does Facebook.
I've ever seen his rants
on Facebook are hilarious.
She is the funniest you.
You would love him.
We hung out together in a,
in Canada together,
inflammatory waits for the responsible
until somebody takes it seriously and
then just goes back and forth with them.
Meanwhile,
starting a new inflammatory posts.
Put them.
He's just on there nonstop
jokes.
Well,
it's a good way to right?
You get a fat supply.
Retards.
He didn't know him and I
just read them on Facebook.
It's a crazy person.
One of the writers forwarded me that.
Kurt was responding to comments.
He was actually was responding to
comments like,
it's really important out of women,
women comics,
there's probably only 10 ever that are
really funny and you're one of them.
You know?
That's crazy.
How many women even had been funny ever
being a dickhead?
Let's say.
We can think of a bunch right now.
Felicia,
Michael's,
Joan Rivers,
rivers.
There's a bunch of
fucking hilarious.
She's fucking hilarious.
That girl does not get her do
really funny.
That'll shock you.
Go see her.
There's a bunch of
girls we never heard of.
I'm sure.
But how many
countries there?
A hundred I now
know that are good.
Seven.
That's a random number
we judging funny because Rocky Lynn,
I know you're funny.
You're funny.
Funny he said,
but,
but he was like,
like,
I was like,
oh,
how was his set like to
ask you about a comic?
And he goes,
he kills.
And I'm like,
yeah,
what was he funny?
He goes,
respect the kill.
And I was like,
okay,
Somebody's lame that is killing
and so many land that's bombing.
I'd way rather have
somebody that's doing well.
You can watch a tell like kind of bomb
once in a while and you're still like,
this is the funniest shit I've ever
seen in my life where he's just always
fucking around and
coming up with new shit,
you know,
if he wanted to.
But it's always hold at classics
and just slaughter isn't,
oh,
he's so fucking funny.
Well,
it's another way.
He's,
he's a real comic,
you know,
there's not so many like real comics.
There's a lot of like weird people
that you have to hang out with.
Why you're doing real comedy.
Like the guy who was one of the actors,
the guy was opening for the annoying
to what you were just talking about
earlier,
who
you'll enjoy them,
enjoy them.
That's not a real cup of coffee.
Coffee.
That guy's a dick.
Wad
totaling up.
No,
he was probably 45
even better
older guys that are
featuring and then I'm like,
Ooh,
Ooh.
It's like,
yeah man,
you're great.
Then the more they like
say they support you,
the more you just see the venom.
Like,
no,
you're great.
Yeah,
my kids love you.
You're like,
you want me to die in the parking lot?
There's always those weird older dudes
used to be at the store that always used
to give the vet.
Those guys that have been around a long
time and they could barely feature on
the road.
They barely even featured
on the road to success.
You're really successful,
but people don't,
people aren't mad at you.
Well,
I guess I'm in New York,
but I never hear of anybody hating on you.
Pretty Nice,
but people are nice that still just get
shit because people are upset about it.
There was
an opportunity to talk.
When you're talking on the podcast,
people get a chance to
like if you see somebody,
yeah,
you see somebody in a movie,
fuck that guy.
That guy's a piece of shit.
Fear factor when,
but when you,
you see a person,
like a podcast allows you like,
okay,
I see like no,
I'm not no perfect person.
There's no perfect person,
but I'm not a bad guy.
I tried to be nice many as often as I can.
It's like as many opportunities
to be nice as possible.
I try to take,
but you're always going to get
someone who doesn't like yet.
There's always going to be people that
are haters no matter what they look at
you or the movement of hate toward
you ever at all from anyone.
Well that's sweet.
Thank you.
Thanks for now.
I'm sure someone out
there will prove me wrong,
but now
you're in the public and someone
is always going to hate you,
but not comics.
I think we all like care about
what comics think about us and
jealousy and whatever.
But yeah,
uh,
people were like,
yeah,
for sure.
I'm like,
watch them again.
You'd be surprised.
Yeah.
Well I definitely got that like from the
people that were like comedy purist or
so,
but it's also because I was
always considered dirty and
for a long time that was
bad.
Like,
um,
when I first started out there was
a bad distinction that was being,
oh,
he's got it.
He's a dirty comic.
Like,
Oh yeah,
for sure.
You were cheap and you were,
um,
you were going for cheap.
Why would they say that?
Well,
because first of all it was Boston and
it's kind of conservative a little bit
socially and it was also that,
you know,
although the very edge,
it was also fairly conservative socially.
And it's also that they had just this
movement and just sort of taking place
where people had gotten the tonight
show and then gotten famous.
It happened with teddy birds,
Ron,
it happened with Steven Wright in a big
way and that they had gotten on these
shows and gotten like this
public attention from television.
So everybody had a nice,
had to have a nice television set.
So the clean people got successful.
Then you became,
when you started thinking like,
well that means they should get success.
Clean equals like [inaudible] was good.
Yeah,
cleaning.
It was good and dirty equals and I
was so confused because I was like,
well,
the reason why I got into
comedy is because I like,
like Richard Pryor and I like Sam
Kinison and like the guy goes,
you know,
look,
you're not like this guy
said to me once like,
you're not dice clay.
I go,
no,
but,
but dice clay like became dice clay.
Like he couldn't have been like really
good when he first started with all these
great form jokes,
but he had a style that
he enjoyed and like,
I'm pursuing a style that I enjoy.
But Boston was very suppressive of that.
They did not.
Yeah,
no.
Dot.
Yeah,
it must be way worse.
I've always said it's way harder
for a woman to do stand up,
period.
Because I think that,
first of all,
there's a lot of bigoted men that don't
want to see a woman in a position of
like the center of attention.
Men don't like that shit.
Yeah.
And they want to be able to like stop
you or a clown you or they'll have their
egos.
Well,
I'll force them to say,
sure,
I want to render you powerless.
When it's why people attack it,
they'll like say something about your
physical appearance because that just
takes away all your power or something.
Yeah.
But yeah,
but also girls have way more of an
opportunity because there is a shortage of
really strong,
um,
working field.
Like when a,
when a festival comes up or like,
who's a killer?
Like,
right.
We will come out here
and just own the room.
Right.
Which,
which requires going on the road
and doing the work for a long time,
long time and uh,
and,
yeah.
And a lot of people,
it just doesn't get,
get to there.
Yeah.
Like the arrogance that you know,
like a lot of like young comics have
like for a female comic it's a way more
slippery slope.
Yeah.
It's really hard to give you a chance.
What before you're ready girls.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah and like the book
rooms ahead of time.
Totally.
Because I'm,
because people,
they want to have a woman in the lineup
they want or whatever and that can,
I mean just me getting on last
comic that early like that.
That was crazy,
but it was like how many were you in
before you got on last calmer to two years
in all my God,
where did you go on John Reape one wait,
John wrote that was what year?
What year was this?
I really
had fun.
Went to was a really tough,
I went to that the first,
second,
second was third and
then on the first one,
I'm sorry ma'am.
I'm like,
now I just,
I'm a dick.
I shot those stories or shows.
It's really nice to see you
have a moment of actual shame.
I've never seen that.
I liked the guy I liked damn fan.
I liked that fan too.
He's a nice guy.
Yeah.
That was the,
that was the first year that they did
last comic standing when they realize that
all these guys that were also in the
show that made it were also being managed
by the producer.
But cats.
Yeah.
When everybody was like,
wait a minute,
what the people that,
and then when you found out that you,
the,
the voting didn't really count that it
was just sort of a ceremonial voting.
It really didn't matter whether or not
like that's why I drew Carey walked off
and prep Butler Butler walked off.
Yeah.
Because they found out that
their vote was not really about,
hey,
we're trying to make a show.
We have the ultimate decision of who's
going to be more entertaining and it just
so happens that people going
to that are more entertaining.
I man and
yeah.
Amy or surprising,
a lot of paypal and the host and the
host and the host time manage what?
A cunt face.
Oh God.
What a fucking a parasite
on the world of comedy.
What do you mean?
Who works with the agencies and
management companies are great people.
Most of them are awesome.
Most of them are all driven by being
proud of how they're living and inspiring
their kid.
You know it's good.
I have the original pilot of that on
VHS with Doug Stanhope Somebody's house.
It's really hilarious.
Someone else hosted after awhile,
like Bill Bellamy,
the host when I did it.
Wow.
What happened?
Why?
Why Jay Morris?
Stop doing it.
Trying to freshen it up a little.
Is that what it was?
Trying to make it a hundred hyper kids
like black people [inaudible] black
occasionally like those frowny
ice cube type black people,
but for the most part we'd like
to keep them on the periphery.
We bring them in.
Bell me,
it's not scary to me.
I'll tell you why right now.
Is he back?
I feel like Bill Bellamy's back.
I don't know Bill Bellamy.
Yeah,
I know he's on the road.
I see like places where like
friends.
Yeah,
different like jail.
Yeah.
That's the only way,
you know,
next week
say that.
But like I love going like weird little
clubs and especially because when I go
I'll go with like,
or Brian or
Dunkin or Joey,
if you can go with friends.
It's always fun.
Like I've never had a
bad time in the road.
I can't remember the Youngstown,
Ohio was not good
the last time.
Was that the one at the
behind the dance club?
Yeah.
That place.
Cleveland's Cleveland's true.
Chicky because it's
economically challenged.
It's very much so,
yeah.
There's spots where you know,
kids are growing up.
We're just no fucking hope in their town.
You know?
Right now where he goes,
he goes,
here's a conversation you ever here?
I'm going to Detroit.
Okay.
Have Fun.
And he said,
yeah,
you just ate up as material
premise for his next special.
I'll go to Detroit.
How Fun.
Chad.
He's so fucking funny.
He does Dallas.
Oh,
that's a classic.
It's impossible to jerk
off to that in 2013
that was funny.
I don't remember.
Are you picturing the carwash?
James' old points really fun.
First of all,
Dave.
So funny.
Like off the cuff and
heres a bunch erotic.
He's got like sheets and
sheets of material and he,
he looked pretty watches the porn goes
over stuff and like he really takes it
super seriously on it.
And then the accuracy,
super respectful
to talk about these films that
they made that were iconic.
Oh,
he has them come back on
with Debbie Dallas.
I did it with a Ginger Lynn.
Oh Wow.
Brian,
no sex.
She was on my first ever comedy
album in 1999 she did a like a,
an introduction to this song that I wrote.
You just randomly placed together or
I forget how I got in touch with her.
I think,
uh,
I think I'd met her through Howard Stern.
I think when I did a,
the Howard stern show,
I met her on that.
Was it that or did it?
It was the comedy store
and that's how I met Jen.
Jenna Jamison come,
we'll walk them through
a porn and make a wish.
Say that again if you're calm while
watching her porn and make a wish,
what happens to everybody to
get in touch with somebody?
Is that how it works?
Like a secret used a secret
project.
Amy,
how do you attribute your hard
work if you didn't use the secret?
I mean,
how did you attribute the success?
Is that what it is?
I think,
I guess all the pain.
I was funny as a kid though.
Yeah,
but then it was totally
my defense mechanism.
How will you
funny.
All right.
What do you like if someone says,
how are you finding,
what is it?
Let's start.
I used to just do,
uh,
Eddie Murphy routines,
pretended they were my own.
Oh,
my fourth grade.
I'm like,
I tell women to get out of the
car and you can't do that anymore,
these days to kick you out of the car.
And my friends are like,
that's not your experience at all.
I'm like,
no,
it is.
Draw.
How's driving driving yesterday
you guys weren't even around.
Yeah.
Then I was like,
oh,
I think I got a ice on this on my own.
I used to tell my friends
like Richard Pryor routines.
Yeah.
Sam Kinison routines.
Oh yeah.
I would like redoing them.
Redoing,
put your own spin on them?
No,
no,
no.
Say like the guy did it.
I didn't try to pass them off as
my own when I said like the guy,
I don't figure that I might've once,
oh no,
I can't remember it.
Heating sand up you,
you may like maybe the talent for it,
that rhythm and whatever.
Yeah.
I sometimes um,
uh,
sat on Youtube where
they're covering my jokes.
They do that Amy Schumer stuff.
Yeah.
And My,
I'm like,
can you guys have them take that down?
Like,
and it'll be a girl like butchering it,
you know,
just like it's so embarrassing.
They should be able to do that.
Be like cover bands in
front of an audience.
Yeah.
Well man,
see Ya.
That was like his whole thing.
Let me use essentially it was just
really good at doing your shit.
Do they say like,
oh,
in front of an audience?
Not like in front of the camera.
Yeah,
no,
it's in front of an audience.
Or they say this an Amy Schumer joke.
I like,
no,
they just do it and then they do it.
But it'll say like,
you know in the description
like this is Amy.
They don't say it while she's being
interviewed and not like she's about to do
all of Amy Schumer should.
She just stole your shit.
I'm like,
can you at least be good at it?
Can you kill with it?
But she likes to use for like doing your
shit in front of some strangers because
the problem is if she
doesn't say it and then they,
that's a hundred people,
whoever,
how many it is,
who don't know that that's your job.
Right.
And so if you ever go and do it,
I saw those jobs.
That's fucking man,
that shit hole.
You stole those from Mindy?
Yeah.
It's fucked up.
I was just like,
I just asked my manager,
can you get that taken off of Youtube?
Maybe?
No.
Do you remember your lawn?
Gold?
Yeah,
I still,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
when he first started,
he does impressions of Comedians.
He's a really good impression as,
but he wouldn't watch them
who would do a comedians,
but he would do it with their
material and that people like,
hey man,
stop fucking doing it.
Yeah,
no,
that's not okay.
You have to be like this is it.
Yeah.
It was the wizard of Oz.
We did you see the comedian?
Yes.
What?
I was just going to say the same thing.
Oh No,
no,
I didn't.
What am I?
God laughs Penn.
There's a guy doing an
impression of Louis.
Oh my God.
It's great.
Fucking right.
No,
pull it up.
Pull it up.
Pull it.
He's half black shell.
Half black is black.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Right.
Look at him.
Leave his face.
Oh,
I'm really snarling.
He's like,
what have you.
You're going to make a half black kid.
That's what we going to do it.
We can fuck that black chicken.
I can see
guys will look like the
hippest Brooklyn cobble pro.
That's the kind of black
Jack I want to go to.
Like clubs where they
play Brazilian music.
Putting it out there with the secret.
You're going to get it already.
So funny.
He does a commercial for his next special,
it's really funny.
Okay,
crank it.
He is a modern day.
He is the most original artists.
Since art was invented.
I did write some more material on a
coffee that most comedians right in their
lifetime,
every hour
it's filmed his most daring special.
I don't know why the
chicken cross the road.
I know some sort of doctor.
That's right.
You Louis Ck is retelling all the greatest
classic jokes in only how it looks
like a
fucking other chip.
Huffington post declares
even walks
stupid.
There's no,
this is the inevitable backlash
of the avalanche of success.
Louis Ck is experience.
I don't know.
Maybe because six
thinks that everything he does is the
greatest in the world and nobody can tell
him what to do.
So he's all shelter on the wall.
What club is that?
Where is it?
Art makes Vishy look like a fucking hat
comedian.
So what's the name of that place again?
The laughing devil have
often goes into Brooklyn.
He's in New York.
In Brooklyn?
I think so.
Oh No.
Long Island.
Silly.
Where's that?
Well,
it's like Brooklyn or Queens.
How many different clubs
are there in New York now?
In 2013.
Eight.
Eight in the city and the city.
You know how fucking crazy that is?
Stop and think about that.
What other city in this God damn
country has eight comedy clubs.
La doesn't even have any comedy clubs.
Maybe.
What does La have?
Let's let's look at la in La.
The city,
we got the laugh factory.
We've got the comedy store.
We got the Improv and then
man,
when I heard it,
we're
not pay money.
Pay Money.
That's not it.
That's not a real common cause.
That's a place where people who are
scared of real comedy clubs go to cuddle.
They should pay.
I'll be on the record with that.
Should pay,
pay Jesus Christ.
Um,
um,
I've been there mixed nuts,
places like that.
Maybe
the,
ha ha ha ha.
Ice Ice House.
Flappers so sex Connie Mack banks.
We're going outside.
No,
we're outside putting
governors of her though.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
Yeah.
We'll wait.
You can't even include Pasadena then.
No.
Yeah,
we can pull through the ice house.
The seller.
That's where we have,
yeah.
What else are we now you're
over that with them now.
I'm sorry.
Already traded.
I would live in New York.
You can we give you Joe Derosa?
He's one of my best friends.
I liked New York and I
could live in New York,
but only if I had a place upstate.
Like I could live,
I could live in New York.
I know cross does that.
He told me like 50 acres
and acres.
But uh,
there's a lot of people
will do it that way.
They have a place up there where they
can go on the weekend and you go and you
see grass and you hear birds,
you know,
like a human.
There's a lake within
a mile of your house,
you know,
that kind of shit.
Yeah.
That's a dope way to do it.
My manager has a place,
I want to say what island,
but he goes out there and
goes fishing and such,
so shut up,
bitch,
fucking ruin everything.
He has his place on an island
and he has to go there.
Like there's no cars.
He goes there that everyone rides bikes
around and he goes there by ferry and
then he has a house there that he
goes to and this fucking nothing.
It's just chirp.
Chirp.
Not really.
Okay.
Fire,
fire island.
Yes.
He's on fire a little bit.
He doesn't even have to
be gay to go to firearms.
I know.
I've been there and it's a blast.
I'm gonna say it.
We'll have to be gay.
I have to get out of here.
Get Out of here because I love you guys.
Please let the function.
Can I get a hug?
Come over here because I want a hug.
We're going to wrap this up with you.
Ari and I will continue to
talk for another five minutes
about you while they're
hugging.
I'll just say that this Friday I'm at
the empower bullshit fear with Joe Rogan
and Bill Burrs,
my farewell to Los Angeles.
I love Ari Shaffir so much that I'm
flying in for the show and then I'm taking
the car to the Improv.
Good and that hug.
Yeah,
somebody gift this,
fill the beat.
Is it up?
Fill it
up so much.
You're a,
did you hear about,
uh,
what happened on America's got talent?
Hold on.
Before you get into that,
Amy Schumer inside Amy Schumer tonight,
you fucks to night tonight at
10 30 Tuesday at 10 30 and 30.
You know what that means?
It means you're edgy.
No.
Like she said,
she,
she was right after a new tosh.
Edgy.
That's good.
That's a perfect spot.
That's pretty bad ass.
God Damn,
that's an awesome spot for you.
Congratulations.
Thanks.
We were supporting the fuck out of you.
All right.
Come back again.
Don't get too big for
your Britches for us.
Oh wait,
I'm saying don't cause I don't
mean to say that for a girl,
a girl.
You can't say that.
A Guy,
you can say you don't get too
big for your britches and they,
they're like,
I got it.
Yeah,
that's it.
Girl.
Joe,
did you hear what happened on a America's
got talent or the guy that stole
material?
Great.
Yeah,
the Greg Wilson.
Apparently he stole
a bit and it just so happens that
the guy's bit was the a warm guy.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it's the original game guy was frank.
Nick tr zero.
Yeah.
And uh,
I guess it's really ridiculous.
Well,
you know,
apparently here's what bothered me more.
I was talking to a boat show about it.
Greg.
I've never heard anything about that.
Really.
Joey Joe,
he told me it doesn't really.
Yeah.
Uh,
but the problem is when anybody does a
bit like how about we all notice this and
it's like,
yeah,
we have,
right?
So if some guy who's going to
start calming seven years from now,
he's also going to notice to
think he thought of it too.
Yeah.
Something similar.
What bothered me more
was Freaknik Tero said,
I've been doing this for
15 years and we're like,
what?
15 years?
Shoot yourself.
Stop.
So in that bit,
yeah.
What are you doing?
Okay.
No,
thievery is never good,
but what are you doing?
He's going Catskill style.
Not doing it every day.
You know,
like maybe he's been doing it
for hopefully fun crowd warmup.
But let's be honest,
a lot of those guys that wind
up with that kind of act,
they do keep going like this.
We know those guys that don't get like
TV spots and not on comedy central that
do the same act.
Yeah,
and they were like middle acts and they
tour round like with the lesser roast.
Yeah.
It's just keep that going.
Listen,
when I went to go buy to think,
right,
like you could get a Mac,
got your lifestyle.
I'm still thinks she went
and won't put his act on Hbo.
You know that because
then you lose your rank.
There's a lot of good jokes.
He won't,
he won't put it on a a special,
he doesn't release any material
and think about Jay Leno.
Jay Leno has been a standup for a long
time and my friend continues to stand up.
He doesn't,
my friends in San Francisco just saw him.
He was just at a corporate event.
What they think of him.
They thought he was okay,
but apparently some people said that
he was a a little bit too risque,
which is hilarious.
I was like,
what are you even saying?
I don't even know what the fuck
words just came out of your mouth.
A little too risky,
but he's doing the same shit.
I mean,
he can write jokes if he wants,
but if you stop and think about the
amount of people that have cds and like,
like think about like what does that,
I see just the guy saying,
I saw frank do that muted fighting couple
bit 15 years ago with the Ice House in
Pasadena.
It was his closer and it killed.
Oh,
that's what someone said
when the guy was on TV.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
just the fuck on.
I would say that if television
at all respect Stanhope,
which at this point we
all know they don't,
they clearly don't.
If they had all respect to stand up,
they wouldn't pass the
guy to the next round.
That was the first reaction.
I'm like,
well,
it was funny.
We'll get into a patsy the next round.
It's like,
no,
no way.
They pass something.
That controversy alone,
she said,
well,
we can't take you until
we have this worked out.
Oh.
But I thought they
kicked him off the show.
Then I think later that frank was so
mad and then they kept talking about it.
They're like,
okay,
let's just not,
well,
I think they didn't
know that it was stolen
until he was actually doing it.
And then while he was doing it,
the warm up guy came over to the producers
and was talking to them and was in
fee and it was thinking
of interrupting it.
Yeah.
So for them to pass him or to say,
well will pass you for now,
like,
like Howard stern was there too,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
they would have had to just say,
okay,
we're going to overlook what we
think may very well be the truth.
We're just gonna overlook
it because you did well.
Well,
if you say you've never heard,
see,
I don't know anything
about the dude's act.
The Greg when he calls
himself the Greg Wilson.
Yeah.
I don't know anything about it.
Sorry.
I've literally never seen him.
I didn't recognize him.
I've never heard a word out of his mouth,
but so I can't say.
Yeah,
so I haven't,
but Joey told me that he heard the guy
was a thief and that he cleaned up his
act like immediate,
been a thief at one point in
time and clean up his act.
But that could be a bullshit rumor too.
It's like if,
if the guy doesn't have a reputation,
if you're saying he doesn't and
he's driving to La all the time,
it is kind of possible that two guys
could have a super similar premise and now
going to say what both went down the
same exact road and went to the same
places.
Maybe,
but it wasn't watching it.
It wasn't like what does
it is exact version.
His version and the ritual.
Yeah,
you do.
Okay.
You little bitch.
So we're going to watch right now.
This is the uh,
supposedly original Frank Nikki Taro
and this guy and a girl car fight.
It's called.
Yeah.
So for 15 years,
just think better be home
like a Samurai sword.
Every flight hit a car
between a guy and a girl.
Sit back.
Enjoy.
Okay.
So he's doing his impression
of where he sits on the stool
for the folks on iTunes.
People on,
usually like I can see some real,
I'm starting off as the
guy who's driving that.
I'll become the girl.
Did I make that clear?
Do you guys need cliff
notes with this shit?
Are you saying you guys aren't Ucla?
Come on,
you're loyal and Mariana.
Oh No,
he did.
I started off as the guy.
I don't get that shot.
Yeah,
he's a guy going,
what?
Oh,
I get it.
It's in the car.
So you can't see.
Right.
That's the idea.
So he's doing what?
He's doing all this shit.
It gives it a finger.
He's going crazy.
Okay.
Now I could say he's doing,
I haven't seen the other guys.
Yeah,
Greg's yet.
They can't say this is easily
something that anyone could think of.
Oh,
it's when you see a couple of
getting into a fight and call.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Well,
it's just a bunch of like,
this guy turns on the rate.
This guy turns on the radio to ignore her.
Yeah.
And he keeps getting really,
really upset by himself.
It's really boring.
He doesn't go for the ice
on the ground right now.
He's doing the girl and now he's like,
I was giving me the finger.
I didn't notice it the first
time he had to push his finger.
That's one thing.
Or like girls do.
They don't even know how to do it right.
But it's basically a bunch
of like mimicking that.
You're upset.
All right.
Now,
have you seen this before?
All right,
so does he do any like particular cues?
That would be something that
like,
all right,
he pulled out of that turning
on the radio to drown her out,
right?
No,
it's not in the second one.
Okay,
let's see.
The other guys now.
Well,
I get it.
I get what this guy said.
There's no joke.
He would cross and they both go to like,
I think it might both go to like a beach.
I at the end.
Oh,
willing maybe,
but there's no crime.
There's crime to get all the details.
It was pretty boring.
He did this for 15 fucking union.
All right.
So now they're like still
arguing back and forth.
Okay.
I've skipped ahead a little bit.
It's basically for the
folks listening to this.
This is fucking Twitter trophy
on the screen at the same time.
No,
no.
Get them both done with.
All right,
so it looks like the
girl and the guy do that.
Someone would make us put screen.
Imagine if like he exactly
copies every movement.
Every movement.
That would be easier.
Chateau.
You could shadow over it
and the guy's honking and
people go around.
I think,
I don't know.
He's leaning over it that Greg doesn't do.
Okay.
Come on.
I can't do this.
This is death.
Scroll to the very end and
it showed the blowjob part.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's coming.
He says,
come on.
Come on.
Whoa.
What's that?
Okay.
God Damn.
Oh,
maybe it wasn't a coach up.
Maybe just put his hand on her.
He put her hand on
[inaudible].
Oh yeah.
He acted like he acted like
put your head down to give a blow job.
Jeremy Hall.
Jeremy House.
Oh,
enjoy Jeremy.
he was middling.
Okay,
so now here is Great Wilson's.
They'll smash brothers
must love this coverage.
They got their sign in the back.
Twins.
That's funny.
Same thing.
Exactly.
Now he's actually be a
little bit more animated.
Greg's kind of wilder
and then he's doing the girl.
She's mocking him.
But here's the thing,
if he did see that guy,
do it,
and then it doesn't
matter if it's different.
Yeah,
he stole it.
but do you know,
how do you
know this gets some e this could easily
be something that someone else thought
of.
It's super possible.
Like here's a perfect example.
I remember when Tony Hinchcliffe the
other day wrote that joke about how the
pope got on Twitter.
Yeah.
It makes sense because the
Twitter just turned seven.
Yeah.
Well turned out someone else
has said that same joke.
I actually told him that.
I was like,
oh,
I saw that.
It goes from where it goes.
I don't know.
A while ago.
Yes,
no,
please tell me you didn't just,
I'm like,
yeah,
I think so.
He thought that someone
else stole it from him,
you know,
and it was like this and meet.
Well,
you know,
well we could say even
though we know it's not true,
but that is the same thing can be said
for your wall bit with them and see a
thing.
This is something that a lot
of people don't know about.
This is kind of crazy crazy thing,
but the wall bit with the
Carlos Admin CF thing,
when people said that,
uh,
well who would build the wall?
Mexicans,
that was like always joke with people
don't realize is that when Ari came up
with that bit,
there wasn't even really a plan to build
a wall where soccer is just starting to
run.
It was a joke,
like Ari made a fake premise and then
made a joke about a fake premise and then
through the ridiculousness of real life,
they actually did start proposing that
we build a wall next to Mexico and that's
when all these dudes start stealing it.
But when our he did it,
he was actually the line about,
that's how I know that
you came up with it first.
No,
no,
they don't have that.
Yes.
So what's the problem?
Really?
What,
who also thinks that we
should get a wall of here,
but then be like,
oh,
who would build it?
It could be a way to go if not from me
seeing him in the back laughing at my
jokes.
Well,
not only that,
he actually did mirror you.
Exactly.
He mirrored your motions,
your hands,
which was like your style.
Like,
oh
well this kind of looks
like he's marrying the same,
touching the leg first year
at the very end of the jokes.
He just went through the whole same shit
and then he's doing the hands and then
he was like looking over.
Yeah.
Oh,
he just looked at,
we didn't get that.
He didn't do the blowjob part.
No,
he just looked over it.
We did a hand light touch.
All touched his leg.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean what I'm saying,
it's the same set up of the
exact same ending with that.
That was the punchline.
I totally say.
I totally said,
okay,
well you know I moved here.
Frank and Nicole tear on.
You're the only one you've
seen doing this for 13 years.
Fifth 15 I'm so,
yeah,
I caught the man short is is dead
actually Greg stopped doing it I guess,
but like it's,
it must be tough to be like,
what the fuck?
That's the all,
I'm the only one who's ever done that.
But it's like maybe
not maybe other people,
but if you find out about it and he was
doing at first you kind of have to drop
it.
You kind of have to drop it.
It's too,
it's too close off.
Freddy to this once about about,
uh,
about something he had and
some young black comics.
I do what I do that same joke.
He goes,
okay.
I'm saying I do that
same exact joke in front.
He was like,
well,
enjoy it.
Yeah,
I'm doing it too,
I hope.
How does it work for you?
Well Brendan Walsh and I had
that situation where Brandon was,
she worried that I stopped
that he was steelo right?
And I said,
no,
it's,
it's a fucking joke about a fleshlight.
Like there's a lot of like obvious
connections to like joking around license.
And I told them,
by the way,
I'm,
I'm done with it.
That was on like my last special.
Yeah.
So it's like,
it's over already.
I already stopped doing it.
Yeah.
Whatever she told me once,
he was like,
I have something that's real similar
to what you're doing and I put it on,
I was like,
oh,
let's stop.
[inaudible]
yeah.
If,
if you doing it now,
and a guy had been doing it before,
like I didn't want
Brendan to stop doing it,
but,
uh,
I wasn't going to get it done.
It.
Yeah.
I would,
I mean,
I,
I already read it rather,
um,
wasn't doing any more,
not that it was going to stop doing it.
I wasn't doing anymore,
so it didn't matter to me,
but I mean,
it's on a special,
you know,
and I think honestly that he absolutely
came up with it on his own because it's,
it's,
it's unnatural premise.
The best is working the booth.
One night after that Chinese spy plane,
the American spy plane went down,
almost hit us Chinese spy plane.
And what did they took our spy plane.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
I watched six comics that night make
a joke about his name being long way.
Yeah.
Six comments.
It's to the point where the
audience is turning around.
It's like,
what's going on here?
What is this a prank on us?
Like,
what's happening?
But everyone is like,
I saw the story and yeah.
Well that was so obvious
and then you realize,
yeah,
yeah.
Well I had that Obama joke like,
uh,
about change and I was like,
oh brother always trying to get money
out of my pocket or something like that.
And yeah,
I saw that.
Like,
I think he saw Joey Diaz do it.
Yeah.
That's why I think you lose touch if
you don't hang out at clubs at all.
Cause you lose touch with
what everybody's doing.
Especially when it
comes to current events.
If there's an issue,
a big thing that happens automatically,
people are going to try to,
right.
Jeff Warren had a crocodile hunter joke
about let's put them in a different
situation with real
people that are dangerous.
You know,
everyone had that.
Well,
I mean even dom Irrera had it
fucking crocodile hunter job.
Everybody did.
I love with ains squeezed the
testicles of this coca dial.
Like everybody just
accepts it to the Russian.
Yeah.
Do you think that there's also clubs in
Los Angeles that are on like the comics
that hang out there plus they don't
police each other as much as like say like
the comedy store.
Cause I know,
I'll tell you what,
there was a situation at the
laugh factory for a while.
Yeah.
Where it was like a den of thieves.
Well I heard that also
about the Haha yeah,
I've heard of
honestly I think that
video you made Brian.
Yeah.
I think that video made comics that
hadn't started yet who are now anywhere
between seven years in and one year in
which would likely the ones who start
stealing.
Yeah.
And the ones that are
around clubs all the time,
those people are more
likely to look out for it.
Now.
Those people are all the ones like,
hey,
I can't wait to catch somebody.
So I think it's like it has put
a serious dent in the problem.
Things
that have happened since then.
Like the patent Oswald one they've got
out and you know there's been a few that
have gotten out where people got and
then just be those people are done man,
they got tortured.
It's over when you steal
a joke today and this day,
like there's a difference between um,
similar premises and and parallel
thinking and then someone who makes it.
It's like obvious man.
When a guy makes a career out of
doing other people's shit every now
and then they try to do
one of their own bits.
When they tried to do
one of their own bits,
well fucking brutally obvious that they,
the,
the humor in these bits is impossible
for them to have also come up with that
other stuff.
It's not,
it's not the same mind.
I saw a guy in San Diego do it once.
One of the new guys there
was like 10 years ago.
Struggle,
struggle,
each promotion then crush on a bit about
taking off a girl's Bra that I saw on
the tonight show like like three,
six months early or whatever it was.
And I was,
and then bomb bomb,
bomb done.
I was like,
yeah man.
Steely.
I used to do this one bit about,
uh,
having an argument with an Arab guy about,
w whose country is more bad ass.
That someone came up to him and said,
you should be very careful.
You know,
like it was so obvious that he wrote that
bit cause it was so dumb and retarded
and clunky and it was like so obvious
that a person who had been stealing for so
long like these I'll get hears.
These are the ones you
came up with on your own.
It's amazing.
You would think though he
would have the format down.
No.
Would at least know the form of no,
this is not,
they're not studying it like a scholar.
They just a burning shit repeating things.
It's like,
it's like watching directions on your gps.
You don't have no idea how to get there.
What's also,
what happens is you
don't learn the language.
There's like a real
subtle language of comedy.
Like you know,
language of music.
Yeah.
Well very similar because
like comedy or like music,
it has a rhythm to it and
there's tension and release.
Yes.
You can get away with the worst
joke if you've made it like,
oh,
what's this going to go?
Oh it's the pledge joke.
Everyone laughs hard and you would think
that someone who knows how to repeat
that shit would also
know how to create it,
but it's not,
it's not how it works because you also,
the mentality that it takes to steel
is the exact opposite mentality that it
takes to sort of open up your mind and
be creative to like to be like empty and
creative.
Like the mentality of a person
who steals is very selfish.
It's very me,
me,
me.
It's very all about getting
it done and you know,
and getting successful and it has nothing
to do with the art of it is you're not
trying to be an artist at all.
Whereas like to be creative you
have to have an artist mentality.
You have to relax,
you have to like let the ideas come to,
you have to respect the ideas
like the Steven Pressfield's book,
the war of art is all about the muse.
Like whether or not the
muse is a real thing.
It's like the concept of like,
like abandoning yourself to the
whim of imbues and working hard.
They don't work hard and working hard.
Uh,
er got off stage the
store and he was like,
saw some new bit and he was like,
Oh man,
you just keep come up with new stuff.
And he's like,
yeah,
I got stuck.
I said,
let's just come so easy for you.
And it goes,
oh no,
make no mistake about it.
This does not come easy for me.
It's not an easy,
but it's,
but it is easy,
you know,
it's not easy and it is easy
once you get a habit for him.
I think humans are just
a form of force of habit.
Yeah.
I've been much more lately
over the last couple months.
It's kind of weird because I have
actually have like last time,
but been,
I mean last time I busy.
Oh,
less time to do right now.
Yeah.
But I'm forcing it in.
I'm making myself do it.
Because you've got that
problem on news radio,
right?
Oh yeah.
During news radio when I first got
on TV I fucking didn't do shit.
And that was a big jump up.
Listen owners.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well I was tired all the
time cause you were on a set,
especially in the beginning it was radio.
Eventually we got it down to her was
where it was like we didn't even have to
show up four days a week.
Like sometimes we only
did three day weeks.
Sure.
Yeah.
We would get the schedule this.
Yeah,
we would get the script in that we block
it the next day and they would shoot it
the next day.
It was like three days.
Yeah.
It was easy.
We knew and the writers
really good and it was,
you know,
it got to a good point.
But so what does it became?
It was long,
long fucking hours.
I got lazy.
Yeah.
I uh,
I just stopped doing standup
and then I'm doing it.
Well No,
I did it,
but I wasn't,
I wasn't writing anything new.
I was like going up with the same old
shit over and over and over again for like
two years.
Like I didn't write anything
new for like two years.
It sounds,
yeah,
it was terrible.
I mean I might have had
like a bit here or there,
but they were dog shit.
I just wasn't focusing on Connie at all.
I was working all day doing the
show and then after it was over,
if I did a set,
it was like a maintenance set.
I would just go up on the weekend and
just do like do bits that I had done.
Just go through the motions.
I wasn't good.
I had lost my,
uh,
my spark and I'd lost the thing that
actually got me to the dance and the first
book,
she got it back.
I can see a lot of people
never gotten that back.
Yeah.
Well that's what I told you.
I saw Tim Allen once and 10 hour and
hadn't done standup in a long time.
And then he went on stage and it was like,
it was like a famous guy.
I've never done standup before.
You would never believe that he was like
this guy who like would dominate and
girl stand up with dominance.
Oh yeah.
For the time.
He was great.
He was moved and the alleys
punchlines and it was powerful stuff.
He was really good at the time,
you know,
like he,
like people wanted to go see that guy.
Like the reason why he got that show.
Cause Yeah.
People loved them.
I mean,
it was,
it was fucking,
it was fucking good man.
I really remember him as a standup.
It was good.
People liked it.
Cool.
But he was not good.
When I saw him.
He was done.
It was over.
It was,
it was a mass.
He had done,
you know,
seven years of home improvement had been
living this bel air mansion lifestyle
and completely out of the loop of comedy
and the grind and getting up there and
that you lose that field.
Would that do to you?
Well,
my set,
um,
I had one set that I fucking eight deck
in front of the writers of Newsradio.
Oh yeah.
I had one of my friends,
uh,
my friend,
Josh Lieb,
who was a writer and I'm a couple of
other people that were there who I really
respected.
I liked them and they,
they went up.
So you know,
it was really late to,
there was no,
there was no energy in the room,
there was no energy.
It was like,
you know,
I was getting on in the main
room at like 1:00 AM ish and um,
it was like at after
don't ever invite people.
We'll see.
I didn't know.
Oh I didn't know.
I didn't know they wanted to
come see me when you get to work.
I'm going to be the
comedy store when I am,
but it wasn't just the 1:00 AM cause I
could do that same 1:00 AM set now and I
would kill for whoever's there.
I'd be fine cause I prepare.
But I didn't know,
first of all I hadn't been doing that
much standup and I hadn't written anything
new and I just wasn't smooth.
I was just bad.
It was awkward and I felt like Shit.
And I remember leaving going,
God damn it,
I can't,
I was really upset with myself
because I've had some bombs before.
But like I could sort of
rationalize them like,
oh I wasn't ready for that time.
I wasn't doing,
I was already a real legit
headliner at that point.
Like I could go on the
road and kill for an hour,
you know,
it wasn't like as good as
the stuff I'm doing now,
but like some of my sex
jokes and all that stuff,
like some of the really old
stuff like it would kill.
It was good.
It was good stuff,
you know?
But I was just,
I was completely out of sorts.
I was saying the words
without thinking about them.
I realized that I had completely left
my focus away from stand up and that
embarrassment forced me to really gear up.
So then I started like doubling
and tripling up on my sats.
I started writing again and then within,
yeah,
within two years I did my
first album and it was,
wait.
Yeah,
I was already way better.
I had completely turned it
around within two years.
I totally,
completely turned it around,
but it was,
um,
one of those things where I realized like,
Oh,
I'm a lazy bitch.
Like I lost my,
the thing that got me to show
business in the first place.
It's amazing how few then whatever,
whatever it does it spark you.
If you then just push like I'm a
comic and I'm going to write this.
Yeah.
You're suddenly turn out this great stuff.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I'm a professional.
That's part of war heart.
You just hired a professional
to write your stuff for you.
Yeah.
This part of the war of art is
being a pro and this is new book.
It's called going pro.
Going pro.
Yeah.
It's fucking great.
It's really inspirational.
It's bad attitude.
Like I'm professional comic,
like you know,
uh,
the other day before a show I did this
show at the state theater and when a new
Brunswick we'll probably the best
set I've ever had in my life,
one of them top 10 ever.
So,
um,
before my set,
I'm in my hotel room and
I like had this attitude.
I'm like,
the next three hours I'm
going to work on my shit.
And I don't do that usually before I,
no,
before I show,
it's like I did a show last night.
I don't know how to do it.
I don't like sit down
and go over all my shit.
But I went over all my shit.
I wrote on my laptop,
I wrote on paper to,
I wrote set lists out on paper and I
wrote bits out on a lot and I worked for
hours.
I dropped Joey off at five o'clock we
had an eight o'clock show and for two and
a half,
three hours.
All I did was right.
Wow.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
And it was one of the
best shows I've ever had.
It was like my mind was like
sparked by the time I got on stage,
we were working it out
already because I'm working,
you know,
you got to,
there's a certain amount you can pull off.
Just do it.
Look,
I come,
I might have a great set right now.
You could just give me
a microphone and it's,
if it's,
if it's a crowd,
my crowd,
I can kind of get into a groove right now,
but to have the best chance of that,
you should really sit down
and go over your shit.
And there was a couple of things that I
said in the set that I had written down
for the first time.
That day you're going over your story
and I turned to get a new angle and that
new angle killed.
There was a couple of new bits
and I had new taglines or angles,
not just fresh but insightful.
Like I had hit a nerve like,
oh,
here's another,
none of nerve a vein.
When you're thinking on stage,
if you're doing it through a bit,
like here's point a,
point B,
point c,
oh it's sparking something in my head
and let's a super quick yes to put it in
between C and D.
I can get it.
But when you're beforehand
and your hotel room,
we got some between c and d like,
oh hold on.
And you could take 40 seconds,
two minutes to think it out.
And now it's like,
oh,
okay.
That's the time I needed that
I wouldn't have had on stage.
You know,
I like talking about bombing.
Um,
and I think it's,
it's,
I like talking about when I was a loser,
I like talking about my failures in life.
I like talking about being
insecure because I've met
so many fucking people that
thank me for that,
that thought that like,
oh here's this guy's been on TV
and he's a host for the UFC calm.
Everything's groovy.
But there's no,
there's no groovy man.
We're just people and it's
a weird ride for everyone.
Maybe blowjob joke used to
suck a dick and I always,
but sometimes it would alienate crowd.
Yeah.
They will get upset.
Like what are you doing?
Yeah.
And then it worked.
It worked it and worked it and it got to
where it's just every time I needed to
figure out a joke to make the biggest
taboo ever funny child molestation,
the most horrible non funny thing.
Well it's,
and people would say,
listen,
trouble state is never funny.
Actually.
Turns out it's okay if the
girl's hot and it's a boy.
That's what Patrice said.
But in the interview where they're like,
have you ever seen her
vape truck is funny?
He goes get my last special,
three of them is there's a way to work
almost everything to the point where it's
funny and sometimes it's an
exercise just to try to get there.
Yeah,
just to see if you can do it.
By the way,
my specialist available right now.
Boom son.
That's how your market shit,
it's called passive aggressive and you
can get it@arishaffir.com right at the
top of the page.
And by the way,
I have heard nothing.
I would not lie to you
and I would not bullshit,
but I've heard nothing but
compliments about that.
So many people told me
is your best shit ever.
And so so many people told me that
they liked it even more than your last
special,
which they liked the album
which we have right here,
which is also available on Itunes,
which is a revenge for the Holocaust.
It's the evil Ari spider
going to both have the same,
actually it's going after a Hitler bug.
Hitler flatter,
leave him alone,
leave him there alone.
Revenge for the Holocaust,
which was by the way,
number one on iTunes bitches.
Everything changed.
Everything
that changed everything.
That was when they all
woke up and they go,
oh,
this guy's for real.
Like I started going to clubs more.
I was like,
I could just do this.
They all realize that have a following,
you know,
one of the opening for you.
It always like,
Oh yeah,
you're funny,
but you know it's tough to Dow man.
I told you like at one point
in time I told you we were,
we were talking about,
I'm like,
well you had,
you were like trying to figure out whether
or not you wanted to do this gig or
you had something else come up.
I go,
dude,
people are coming to see you.
Like you've got to realize
they're coming to see you too.
They,
and they will eventually
follow you somewhere there.
There's not a lot of opportunities
to get in front of a thousand people.
You can get in front of a
thousand feet especially,
but then we were doing clubs,
so it'd be over a weekend,
the thousand people over the weekend.
If you can get in front
of a thousand people,
you can make a thousand fans
and then it thousand fans.
How many of them going
to remember your name?
Well,
if they're real fans of ours,
they're going to be paying
attention to this whole loop.
So you enough.
Don't remember.
You don't remember you,
they saw you.
We started doing shows and then the
real highlight of it wasn't Toronto,
which uh,
I have on my fucking phone somewhere,
but I'm not going to find it.
I tried to find it the other
day when you weren't here,
when were talking about
it in Chicago coming up.
You went on stage Tripoli,
Bro.
Yeah,
you went on stage and the
fucking place went crazy.
Toronto,
Toronto Massey Hall,
Dude,
it's 3,400 people in there.
And when you went on stage,
they were cheering for
like 30 solid second.
Holy Shit.
Well that was when you realize like,
oh my God,
they're my fans too.
And then you were off to the races and
then from there it's like all of a sudden
your headline and all these
places and you're selling out.
And all these places and sometimes
all it takes is like one tweet,
boom.
Let them know,
let them know like that guy,
you know he's here.
Well that's the beautiful
thing about my Twitter page.
Yeah.
And it's like,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
a new distribution center.
It's like,
Oh,
Ari Shapiro,
governor special out.
You know,
Joey Diaz is in Montclair,
you know,
Brian red bands in Sacramento.
Like you can,
you can use it and like you,
you can just bump everybody up.
Everybody just pushes,
everybody gets pushed into mainstream
and then everyone's got a career.
Toronto's soak such a good mark.
I'm going there the beginning of June.
Toronto's amazing.
I'm going outside Ontario.
I'm going to Hamilton in London just
cause I'm like this places that are two
hours outside,
let's go there to Toronto is the shit.
That's one of my favorite cities ever.
The people are,
it's like a city with nice people.
It doesn't even make sense.
And I know there's some
Douche bags in Toronto,
New York with Nice people.
Yeah.
Nobody's angry.
Well,
I'm sure some people were looking to you,
but it's like,
it's a notice will be different tone
than the average American gigantic city.
Toronto is a cool city.
Yeah.
As is Chicago.
Chicago is very much like that in America.
I know Chicago gets a lot of murders,
but I'll tell you,
man,
I fucking love Chicago people.
Yeah.
There's some fun people.
They're like the nicest kind of people
that you find a new drink so hard and
they eat hard.
Oh yeah.
That's salary.
Hat.
[inaudible] Salad,
sugar.
It is sugar all over pizza for like,
what does that,
what do you it up?
This is the best pizza
in Los Angeles isn't it's Chicago.
Where's that?
Montereau valley.
California malicious though.
The guys from Chicago,
he's the one that always brings me
to where to they ding Dong shows.
Remember that guy?
Have you ever ate that pizza?
Where's the playground valid?
I think it's like an hour
away from Los Angeles,
but just brings up pizzas
for us all the time.
But it's so good.
Do me a favor and put my Boston
date on the Twitter page.
You're going to Boston.
Uh,
I'm going in July.
There's a UFC there.
What are you doing?
The,
the um,
Wilbur?
Yeah.
Well where the first
show is already sold out.
That's your hometown.
Yeah.
First show sold out,
but I'm doing another one.
Um,
it's a,
it's August 16th.
Oh,
it's August to him.
They just added that.
That's hilarious.
It's already sold out and it's an August.
That's your hometown?
That's a homecoming.
Yeah,
man.
Almost sold out in the first day.
It's just when the tickets just
went on sale the other day.
I don't get to Boston and not for,
it's one of the best places
they were to perform.
And I'm,
maybe I'll fucking record my new shit.
They're just the perfect time.
Boston do it back home.
You have two shows at a theater,
a fight
stuff,
right?
No,
it's all new.
It's all new.
It's 100% knew from my last special.
It was not one to decide not
to do it at comedy works.
That's not a bad second.
Yeah.
It's not fun to come home situation.
Well,
it's also like the Wilbur's a weird
theater cause it's a thousand people,
but they're all like right in your face.
It's like there's the bottom
level of like a club chairs,
tables and then it goes cedar
and the balconies fairly low.
There's still like right in your face,
you know,
so,
uh,
if I decide to do it,
I'll let you guys know if
I decided to do it there.
But you know,
like for emotional reasons,
it's probably a good place
to do it because it's like,
that is my,
that's where I started started.
I will always have a devotion to Boston
comedy and the Boston comedy scene and
you know,
it's like that's,
there was no place like that in the 80s
there was no place in the world like
that spot.
And you know,
and so like that,
it's not like that anymore.
You know?
I Know Austin has a scene and I know that
San Francisco has a scene and there's
scenes all over the country,
but Boston doesn't have the
same scene that he used to have.
It used to have the US scene.
It was the place.
It was like,
there was these media centers like New
York and la where everybody aspired to go
to.
But then as far as like the place where
that was just pumping out savages,
you know,
like,
look at all the guys
that came from that era.
Anthony Clark,
a lot of people don't respect.
Now we're watching on TV and
lucky he was fucking bad.
Actually in the 80s.
I'm telling you,
Anthony used to kill
Louis C K David Cross,
Nick Depaulo teres put Teresa Neal,
Bill Burr Dude.
Stop and think about that.
Um,
uh,
but mark Marin,
um,
yeah,
dude,
these are all Boston guys and Steven.
Right?
But that was before Lenny Clarke.
I mean,
you can keep going on and
on and on that one spot.
That little shit.
Shithole city pumped out
a fuck load of comics.
High level comics,
man.
Yeah.
Greg Fitzsimmons.
Oh yeah.
Did I forget Greg?
Dude,
I did his podcast at cap city.
They did a live one.
Greg had one.
Yeah.
Uh,
but I was there for Moontower.
Anyway,
so this is the,
this is,
it's Fitzsimmons,
Janine Garafalo and Andy Kindler.
Ooh,
yeah.
And me in the middle.
I'm just looking at all of
them at some point I'm like,
what am I doing here?
Yeah.
Well Fitzsimmons in you makes sense.
But he tend to,
when I started Fitzsimmons
is already like a made guy.
Oh,
you mean as far as like status wise.
Yeah.
So you're still trying to accept the
fact that your religion at comic?
Yeah,
I guess so.
I guess that's what it this,
while you're more legit than kindler.
I love Kindler,
but you're much more
legit than kindler you.
He can't sell out of club for a weekend.
I guess it's just that when I
shouldn't be mean about that.
But you start and I say that.
Yeah.
But I say that because I don't think
kindler gets the respect that he deserves.
And I think also because Keller is kind
of like the ultimate back of the room
crowds.
It's hilarious.
It's very,
very,
very funny whisker off a low,
like a political as fuck,
but also really nice political as fuck.
Yeah.
She saw into that stuff.
It's kind of a silly game,
right?
It's fucking shows over folks.
Yeah.
We love you.
You Love Ari?
Yup.
All right.
You fucks.
Um,
party on prosper,
Godspeed,
all that.
Um,
I can tell you about all
the podcast sponsors again,
but I think you probably
heard all this shit before.
I have a spot cast.
Oh,
he has a podcast called
Ari Shaffir skeptic tank.
Yeah.
Tom Rhodes was on this week.
He's not necessarily even
skeptical about everything.
That's just a good name.
Yeah.
Just me questioning.
Just it is what it
[inaudible] powerful road dog.
Tom Rose.
Sharon asked him,
he said,
where are you living now?
He goes in there.
Nice shoes,
man.
Wow.
That's that.
Go spot the spot.
That's a legit fucking crazy person.
Yeah.
I couldn't do that.
Good.
But I can't now.
He met a girl and got married.
He was like,
if you want to do this,
you've got to pair down.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And she's down.
She's with them.
She said she goes with him
everywhere on the road.
Two,
three.
How's their whole life?
Oh my God.
And every weekend is a club or festival.
Wow.
That's a woman that's willing,
willing to live your life.
Yeah.
About her own life.
But if that life is cool to see the world,
hey,
look at Doug and Bingo
Shit works sometimes.
Harlow,
Sacramento,
Ladies Gentlemen.
Yeah.
Brian red bands can be doing
comedy Sacramento this weekend,
Friday and Saturday,
and then Sunday cops,
um,
along with Tony Hinchcliffe,
the whole area's Sab,
Tripoli.
Hilarious.
So it's a good time.
Um,
thank you for everything.
Thanks for,
thanks for all the Twitter messages.
Tell your fans,
man,
thanks for all the love we loved them.
Pump.
Say,
tell them,
tell them we love to fans.
You fuckers coming out in support and
comedy and you're keeping it real.
It's a mutual exchange.
You help us be better at
everything and we love you.
All right.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Yeah.